So Leute wir müssen jetzt schauen ob ich noch 5 header genug bin um 18.58 irgendwas sinnvolles
zu machen.
Kann sein das es nicht funktioniert sag ich euch gleich schonmal.
Ateno Pock so siehts aus Pock Massive Subscriptions hier wieder 6 Monate ist er am Start ne 7 Monate
Massive Subscriptions Sariks Moin Der Meister zieht zu Aua am Start ich war grad
schon Der Chat lag critical information Österreich Du meinst Australia
Aus Irland jetzt kommen sie aber aus allen Ecken und Enden der Welt
So mal gucken ob ich heute noch genug 5 Head im Hirn übrig habe dass wir heute noch ein
bisschen was basteln können mit GitHub Actions und vor allem automatisches Bild für ne Anwendung
ich zeig euch das ich erklär euch das gleich ja ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher ob das überhaupt
ne gute Idee ist und ob das funktioniert aber ja besser als jetzt muss man das irgendwie
machen ist GitHub Actions arg anders als GitLab ich hab ehrlich gesagt diese GitLab CI Geschichte
nur sehr rudimentär verwendet also die Definition im Jaml sind auf jeden Fall ein bisschen anders
so viel kann ich dir sagen aber so Einzelheiten habe ich keine Ahnung die Auswahl an GitHub
Actions ist wahrscheinlich größer wobei ich ganz ehrlich nicht ganz verstehe was manche
Leute da treiben ich sehe da teilweise GitHub Actions die sind irgendwie 50 Seiten lang
und bestehen nur aus Jaml und einzig und allein aus dem Grund weil sie für jeden Schritt
eine eigene Action wollen anstatt einfach mal zwei 2 Zeilen Shellscript hintereinander
zu schreiben also manche übertreiben es dann ein bisschen ich zeige euch mal was wir probieren
der 4er Champ ist am Start ja mit dem machen wir heute nichts ich zeige euch aber mal was
der Stein des Anstoßes war Moment erstmal kurz Hacker Time aktivieren exellent so jetzt
geht es jetzt was das ist von den Raspberry Pi keine Ahnung ach wir machen mal kurz während
ich erzähle mache ich mal kurz Update bei ist Dankeschön für den Sub machen wir mal
Update schad nix was will replace werden at SPI 2 ATK alles klar jaja mach mal was auch
immer er da replaced warum habe ich eigentlich immer noch nicht auf diese FM Multi Multiple
Downloads angemacht chat kann ich mir das sagen warum mache ich keine Multiple ich weiß
warum ich keine Multiple Downloads habe weil der Stream geleckt hat mit Multiple Downloads
es hat keinen tieferen Sinn du kannst beliebig oft den Kram hinten dran schreiben kannst
auch u u u u u machen während die vm startet chat Sekunde Sekunde ich ich muss ich muss
mir die volle Weeber Ladung geben Sekunde das geht gerade nicht anders Weep Overload
alles klar so 10 Sekunden 10 Sekunden so ok vorbei cute genug gewesen warum kein Dark Mode
ist doch Dark Mode was denn ach so du meinst hier keine Ahnung ich habe das eh immer auf
Fullscreen ich habe Multiple Downloads an guck mal da macht auch Multiple Downloads
dann weiß ich auch nicht warum am Anfang nicht Multiple Downloads hat was ist das für
eine Distro Arch by the way selbstverständlich wobei man das gar nicht mehr sagen darf man
Jaro ist ja offiziell gar kein Arch Linux also doch ist es ist ein Arch Linux aber es
ist kein offizielles Arch Linux und es ist nicht blässt vom Arch Linux von den Päpsten
des des Arch Linux Blessens das ist das Noob Arch Linux sozusagen ich will schon lange
umsteigen auf ein richtiges Arch Linux aber ich hatte bis jetzt noch keinen Bock die vm
fertig einzurichten ganz ehrlich eigentlich ist überhaupt kein Ding das ist mittlerweile
fast genauso schnell eingerichtet wie Ubuntu letztendlich ist ja das was was bisschen Aufwand
macht es sind deine individuelle Konfig ja ok vorbei nicht ganz ich mein du musst schon
noch die Packages installieren soll standardmäßig kein X dabei wenn du es im Minimal install
machst ja ein bisschen mehr musst du schon machen aber es hält sich wirklich in Grenzen
jaja mit dem install script ist gar kein Ding aber da hast halt immer noch nichts drauf
also du musst jetzt immer so du musst du musst X installieren du musst vor immer Tools
in meinem Fall installieren und dann musst du gucken dass ein paar Sachen automatisch
startest aber großer Akt ist es nicht wir haben da sogar mal hier Archive wo Blorts
wir haben sogar mal vor nicht allzu langer Zeit ein Arch Linux Arch by the way Einrichtungs
Stream gemacht 5 sag mal war das der längste Stream den ich je gemacht habe oder was 5
Stunden 16 ist da mit mir los gewesen
und das audio war es ein so es ist so jetzt haben wir geupdatet gab es einen Köln wir
kommen kurz aufs ein kernel update gab ein update haben wir denn hier das ist ja ach
LTS ok der LTS können wir drauf bleiben ok exellent so also ich erzähle euch jetzt mal
was was ich mir überlegt habe und zwar es geht heute überhaupt nicht um dieses Pro
ekt im Detail sondern mir ist eine Sache dabei aufgefallen also wenn ich weiß was es ist
ich sag es ganz kurz das ist ein Addon für Home Assistant wo man aus seinem aktuellen
Fiat Werte auslesen kann und und in seine Heimautomatisierung bringen da sieht man dann
sowas in seinem Dashboard aber da geht es überhaupt nicht rum da ist mir was aufgefallen
und zwar die ganze Zeit also das geht das wird über Docker gebaut und läuft dann als
Home Assistant Addon das ist so ein Standard wie agil ist die Agile Poggers Organisation
die ist so agil dass da nicht jeder reinkommt die ist close source sozusagen weiß gar nicht
wer das Ding angelegt hat der Poggers war das glaube ich oder ich weiß gar nicht irgendjemand
hat das mal angelegt gut logisch wer soll das sonst angelegt haben irgendjemand muss
es angelegt haben also ob wir es nie hatte hat er eigentlich auf den Issue geantwortet
jetzt also holen am arsten das ist ein Home Assistant Addon das wird über Docker gebaut
so da gibt es ein Dockerfile da muss jetzt mal kurz zurückgehen dass ich euch war dass
ich euch das erklären kann was wir jetzt eigentlich vor ich gehe mal hier irgendwo dahin zurück
so browse files Dockerfile von diesem Comment so vor paar Tagen sah das Dockerfile noch
sehr übersichtlich aus das sieht immer noch übersichtlich aus und das hat folgendes gemacht
das hat das Standard Bild Image für Home Assistant runtergezogen hat das Runscript
hinkopiert hat die Anwendung hinkopiert hat irgendwie paar Dependencies installiert hat
dort net installiert und das wars so und wenn du das angeklickt hast dann wurde das immer
also wenn du das Addon installiert hast dann wurde das Addon immer auf dem Client System
gebaut also sprich irgendjemand hat in seinem Home Assistant angeklickt ich will das Addon
installieren und dann hat er das runtergeladen und hat dort ein Docker Bild gemacht das war
praktisch weil da musste man sich keine Gedanken machen ist es ist es AMD ist es Arm oder also
ist es x86 64 ist es 32 Spit Arm ist es 64 Spit Arm oder was auch immer ist egal weil
es wurde auf der Ziel Plattform gebildet so jetzt gab es nur ein kleines Problem das
zeige ich euch mal in dem Issue da gab es nur ein kleines Problem achja und in dem Run
SH steht auch nix großartiges drin der setzt Passwort und Username für das Login und am
Ende sagt er hier.net run oder eben wenn es Debug ist oder er sagt.net run release
das war von der Idee her tatsächlich ziemlich praktisch erstens konnte man ein bisschen
Debug Ausgaben einbauen mit so einem Frontend Switch man hat nämlich wenn man das anklickt
wenn man das hier in den Addon Settings anklickt dann kann man hier Debug an und aus machen
und wenn man Debug an und aus gemacht hat dann gab es also wenn man Debug angemacht
hat da gab es ein bisschen mehr Meldung falls das Ding mal kaputt gegangen ist dass ich
besser nachvollziehen kann was kaputt gegangen ist so das Problem war nur ich zeige euch
mal das Issue das Problem war nur dass irgendwelche Leute reported haben das Bild ist kaputt
das Bild funktioniert nicht so und da habe ich ihn gefragt kann es sein dass es am Raspberry
Pi liegt da habe ich ihn erstmal gefragt kann es sein dass es am Raspberry Pi liegt
aber ich hätte mir damals schon denken können dass es an der RAM Auslastung liegt weil
das Ding ist einfach gecrashed ohne irgendwelche Meldungen das kann durchaus mal passieren
wenn der RAM komplett weg ist dann macht einfach den Container aus bzw. schießt da drinnen
wahrscheinlich irgendwas ab deswegen merkt man das nicht also der hat reported hier guck
mal Container geht nicht habe ich ihn gefragt liegt es daran dass es am Raspberry Pi läuft
vielleicht weil ich habe es am Raspberry Pi zum damaligen Zeitpunkt auch gar nicht richtig
getestet so dann geht das weiter bla bla bla bla bla so und ein paar Tage später kam er
nochmal und kam er hier auch noch und meinte bei ihm crash das ganze auch und dann meinte
er es scheint ihm dass das addon etwas viel RAM benutzt und dann dachte ich erst die Amazon
Library braucht viel RAM das Problem ist nur dass das addon nach dem Start über 600
ist noch wenig das ging teilweise auf 750 MB hoch überlegt euch mal einen addon was
nichts anderes macht als ein paar HTTP Request zu schicken 700 bis 750 MB RAM Auslastung
also das ist das Video habe ich noch nicht aufgenommen aber das das wird höchstwahrscheinlich
wieder fail mit Ansage werden also ich kann euch auch in die Kurzfassung sagen ich gehe
davon aus dass der breite also Gigabit Ausbau ist es ja dass der Gigabit Ausbau in Deutschland
ganz gut vorankommt die nächsten Jahre über weil die nächsten Jahre über ist das Ziel
ja auch bloß 60% das schaffen die da gehe ich mal von aus sie werden wahrscheinlich
das nicht einhalten exakt bis zum stich der aber das schaffen die weil 60% ist gar kein
Problem 60% kannst du 60% Haushalte anschließen wo sich's lohnt problematisch sind die letzten
40% oder eigentlich gesagt die letzten 10% sind eigentlich eher das Problem da wo sich
nämlich eigentlich nicht wirklich lohnen würde und dann hast du noch die Opas die
sagen warum soll ich in mein Haus warum soll ich den Gehweg vom Haus aufbuddeln lassen
für Glasfaserkabel und sonst was ich glaube die 60% schaffen sie und den Rest wird so
wie bisher nicht funktionieren weil man muss auch mal sagen wir haben noch nie zumindest
ist mir keine bekannt wir haben noch nie unsere selbstgemachten Breitband Vorgaben eingehalten
noch nie ich lasse mich gerne eines besseren belehren alles was ich bisher gesehen habe
alles was ich bisher nachgeguckt euch verfolgt das Thema schon lange wir haben es nie eingehalten
nie nicht einmal und es gibt Vorgaben schon seit fragt mich nicht 1997 oder so die machen
wir uns ja auch selbst das Problem ist nur dass wir immer so diese Vorgaben eigentlich
nie vor haben umzusetzen sondern das immer so als Marketing Material verwenden so nach
dem Motto bis Ende 2015 haben alle mindestens das und das und dann bis dahin Gigabit und
bis dahin dass wir haben eigentlich nie wirklich geschafft und nie wirklich vor gehabt das
zu machen jetzt sagen sie es mal wieder und ich gehe davon aus dass wir es wieder nicht
einhalten werden weil bis 2025 alle anzuschließen 60 prozent anschließen das gehe ich davon
aus das kriegen wir hin aber der Rest ist halt das Problem also ich meine ich muss ehrlich
sagen ich kann jetzt erstmal damit leben ich habe seit einer ganzen Weile 400 MBit runter
40 MBit hoch das reicht sogar mir für YouTube Videos in 2k hochladen würde auch für 4k
reichen das ist kein Ding funktioniert wunderbar also ich bin damit erstmal glücklich vielleicht
ich kann mein Vodafone Kabel noch upgraden auf Gigabit wenn ich irgendwann mal wieder
Bock habe mit Vodafone zu diskutieren und das war es ja das ist ja auch ein Problem
sie sagen überall Glasfaser Glasfaser soll überall hin am Ende und ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher ob das wirklich eins zu eins drin steht dass es Glasfaser sein muss aber am Ende
wird es eh darauf rauslaufen dass Gigabit wieder ein äußerst dehnbarer Begriff sein
wird so nach dem Motto wir haben eine Shared-Leitung die Gigabit kann das ist doch Gigabit oder
wir haben da ein Funkmast wo man theoretisch Gigabit drüber funken könnte und solche
Geschichten also da bin ich da bin ich echt mal gespannt hast du Dual-Stack bei ja habe
ich echt ein Dual-Stack IPv4 und IPv6 aber ihr kennt ja meine Meinung zu IPv6 ich gehe
nicht davon aus dass ich IPv6 wirklich jemals komplett durchsetzen wird bevor das passiert
macht Google was eigenes und ich weiß dass es mit dem heutigen Stand so ohne weiteres
nicht möglich ist weil alle Web-Services beziehungsweise so gut wie alles basiert halt
darauf dass es oberhalb von IP ist aber wenn die alle an einem Strang ziehen dann lässt
sich da auch etwas weiter unten im Stack was basteln wenn Google dabei ist Microsoft dabei
ist und die üblichen Verdächtigen wenn es wirklich wenn der Schuh drückt dann schütteln
die sich da irgendwas aus dem Ärmel warum nicht ich kann mir das richtig gut vorstellen
die haben das besser ob das besser ist sei mal dahingestellt da habe ich so besser wird
das wahrscheinlich nicht sein es wird wahrscheinlich angenehmer für Google und Microsoft sein
in der Umsetzung ich meine ist es nicht so dass sogar Amazon immer noch nicht über IPv6
erreichbar ist also ich ich vermute mal ich vermute mal es wird folgendermaßen laufen
bevor sich IPv6 durchsetzt drückt der Schuh so stark dass sich die üblichen Verdächtigen
zusammensetzen und irgendwas wie auch immer geartetes abartiges konstruieren was rückwärts
kompatibel zu IPv4 ist irgendwas wo dann in aktuell noch reservierte Netzplöcke irgendwie
mit irgendeinem Encoding mehr rein encoded werden kann als vorher ganz wirres Zeug wird
das werden ich bin mal gespannt ich bin ich bin echt mal gespannt ich ich kann mir das
bildlich vorstellen noch mal irgendwas irgendwas so nach dem Motto wenn das das nimmt dann
das nimmt auch ganz merkwürdige Ausmaße ran an das wird dann so was werden wie wenn
die letzten zwei bits auf eins sind von jedem achter block dann guckt der neue Netzwerkstack
nach ob es nicht noch ein weiteres byte hinten dran gibt und so was ganz ganz abartig wird
das werden ihr das macht doch nichts wenn die richtigen Hersteller am zusammensitzen
dann dann können es das halt dann kann es das halt ich kann mir das gut vorstellen
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen wie sie es genau machen wollen weil wirklich passende
hast schon recht wirklich rein passen tut das nicht was er vielleicht IPv6 vielleicht
vielleicht nicht aber ich kann es einfach gut vorstellen dass das sowas kommt dass
sie sich da irgendwas aushecken wer dass das natürlich keiner wirklich haben will außer
denen beziehungsweise dass man einfach sagen will ja wäre schon gut wenn sich IPv6 endlich
mal komplett durchsetzt ja ja schon klar aber das ist einfach so ein Szenario das wird
zu gut passen ja keine ahnung was da wieder los ist ja vielleicht denken sie sich auch
noch irgendwelche erweiterungen aus dass du dann quasi keine ahnung ich habe keine ahnung
was es genau sein könnte ich weiß nur wenn sowas kommt also ich kann mir dieses Szenario
einfach gut ausmalen im kopf und wenn es was kommt dann wird es was komplett abartiges
sein wie gesagt sowas in der richtung wie letzten zwei bitt gesetzt so ein bisschen
nach dem motto wie utf acht feststellt ob das zeichen noch weiter geht da ist es ja
auch so gerade dabei sind da ist es ja auch so ähnlich ich sage nicht genauso ja dass
wir machen mit dem home assistant add-on weiter also wir nehmen wir bauen dafür heute ein
paar bill scripts also in utf acht ist es ja auch so das kann er theoretisch glaube
sogar dass es theoretisch mehr könnte wenn das letzte ist egal zumindest utf acht ist
auch so ein ding utf acht ist rückwärts kompatibel zu aski so und wie machen sie das
folgendermaßen also diese zeichen hier sind aski technisch belegt die machen das jetzt
so wenn das letzte wenn die nicht dass ich jetzt wenn die letzte hälfte des ich bin
mir gar nicht sicher kann sein dass ich euch misst erzählen aber so ungefähr ungefähr
ist es wenn die letzte hälfte des bytes auf eins steht dann bedeutet das das nächste
byte gehört noch zu diesem zeichen dazu was meint ihr wie man emojis encoded in utf acht
das sind vier bytes wovon das erste byte signalisiert es geht weiter das zweite byte signalisiert
es geht weiter bis man halt beim vierten byte ist das hangelt sich auch da lang also es
gibt ein ein ein ein flag in utf acht woran man erkennt ob das zeichen weiter geht was
ja auch wichtig ist was ja so nur nicht funktionieren würde weil utf acht ist halt variabel utf
acht ist standardmäßig erst mal nur ein byte einfach dass es rückwärts kompatibel
zu aski ist und wenn das wenn das ich selbst dieses geht weiter bit gesetztes dann ist
das nächste dann ist quasi utf dann ist es quasi utf 16 ist es nicht wirklich utf 16
es ist zwei bytes ist es so und ja guck hier da sieht man es doch da sieht man es da sieht
man es doch hier also die jetzt das erste byte geht von in diesem bereich 128 entspricht
acht bit entspricht utf acht genau dem aski code das höchste bit ist null die restliche
sieben sieben kommen jetzt das aski zeichen so wenn das eins ist dann geht es mit dem
nächsten zeichen weiter so würde ich das jetzt nochmal interpretieren es ist ganz
mir so und in dieser richtung kann ich mir genau ist das höchste bit des ersten bytes
null handelt sich um aski zeichen so blablabla so ist das höchste bit des ersten bytes
eins handelt es sich um ein mehr byte zeichen also ein unicode zeichen mit einer zeichnummer
größer als 127 das heißt ist das letzte bit eins dann musst du das zweite bit noch
einlesen weil es zum zeichen dazu gehört emojis by the way sind in der regel vier
byte das heißt das ist dann dargesetzt dargesetzt dargesetzt dargesetzt so und genau so was
in der richtung könnte ich mir vorstellen als ip 4,5 oder sowas ja wollte ich also richtig
habe ich auch gerade was zugesagt ich habe gerade die kurzfassung dazu erzählt und sowas
könnte ich mir auch vorstellen als quasi ipv5 oder sowas dass die irgendwie in nicht
benutzte blöcke was rein encode und wenn man dann nachguckt dann kommen noch zwei bytes
hinten dran aber normalerweise nicht und deswegen kann man irgendwas in der richtung glaubst
mir es wird was ekliges wenn die sowas machen wenn die sowas machen dann wird es was ekliges
ich habe auf auf watch immer noch nicht runtergeladen ehrlich gesagt was will der chainlord denn
was hat er gefragt zu overwatch 2 näher zu overwatch 2 habe ich schon nichts gesagt
weil ich auf overwatch 2 noch nicht gespielt habe und zu stadia habe ich schon oft genug
gesagt und dass die jetzt den laden dicht machen das war ja nur eine frage in der zeit
mich hat es gewundert dass es so lang gedauert hat wahrscheinlich hat google irgendwie so
eine interne policy dass man vor drei jahren kein projekt schließt erinnern euch noch
dran mit welchem tamtam stadia gestartet ist ich habe mir damals schon gedacht wer zum
teufel wer soll das wirklich ansprechen am ende hat es halt keiner angesprochen genauso
wie dieser komische logitech hand hält wo ich mir auch gedacht habe warum freuen die
sich auf twitter alle so das ding ist komplett unsinnig vor allem weil ich mich halt so denke
was willst du da wer wer ist die wer will das wer will das haben niemand will cloud gaming
haben die kaknubs die wollen kein cloud die kaknubs für die theoretisch cloud gaming
eine alternative wäre so um irgendwie ihr single player zeug zu spielen und einen desktop
zu brauchen oder konsole haben keine ahnung von cloud gaming und wissen nicht mal was
das ist wisst ihr was die übelsten kaknubs haben wollen die übelsten kaknubs die übelst
die ultra casuals die zwar mobile games konsumieren aber ab und zu auch mal ein ordentliches single
player spiel spielen wollen wisst ihr was die haben wollen die wollen playstation oder
nintendo daheim haben die haben keine ahnung von von was die wissen noch nicht mal dass
das ding switch heißt die wissen nicht mal dass das ding xbox heißt die wissen nur ich
will playstation und nintendo und dann kaufen die sich playstation und nintendo die haben
für die wäre vielleicht cloud gaming eventuell eine alternative aber die haben keine ahnung
die checken es nicht und die wollen es auch nicht checken so und deswegen wird es halt
nix für wen soll dann cloud gaming sein für unterwegs schon mal gar nicht weil internet
verbindung taugt nix für wen soll das sein also ich verstehe es nicht cloud gaming ist
irgendwie wie ich verstehe es nicht für wen das was sein soll so und mobiles gaming jetzt
mal unabhängig von der switch oder mobile games das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen
dass es da für leute gibt ich meine das steam deck das verkauft sich ja wohl ganz gut bin
immer noch nicht so ganz sicher was ich damit jetzt machen würde weil ich meine ich fahre
zwar mit dem zug aber nicht so lange dass ich dann steam deck aber ja ich also ich kann
es mir zumindest vorstellen wer das gebrauchen könnte ich wüsste jetzt für mich nicht wozu
so richtig aber hey ok was sage ich mit dem highlight videos geworden mit was denn für
mein video so da müsste ich jetzt mir erst mal gedanken machen was mit so einem steam
deck machen soll aber ich verstehe warum man ein steam deck hat und steam deck an sich
finde ich ist auch eine sinnvolle geschichte weil es halt pc spiele spielen kann und das
gar kein so schlechter pc ist ich meine das ist kein guter desktop pc aber das ist für
so ein mobiles ist das schon ok also das verstehe ich das hat durchaus zukunft ich könnte
mir vorstellen wenn andere hersteller was bauen in der richtung könnte das könnte das auch
funktionieren aber an sich cloud gaming als alternative nee das muss lokal auf dem gerät
laufen wenn ich im zug sitze will ich mein spiel spielen und ich ruckeln weil lte nicht
funktioniert das kommt ja noch dabei ich habe ein video geguckt das wusste ich gar nicht
dieses logitech ding hat noch nicht mal ne sim karte du kannst doch nicht mal mobil spielen
also den sinn verstehe ich überhaupt nicht reiter ross dankeschön für den 12 monaten
messer piper subscriptions negativ latent sie hatten sie aber das ja bastard ja so viel
bullshit erzählt wahnsinn rüber wollte man die cd auch lokal im audiosystem haben ja
wenn du kackverbindung hast es ist immer noch sinnvoll lokal die musik auf dem handy zu
haben selbst heute noch wobei es meistens funktioniert weil dein gerät buffert was
bei einem singleplayer spiel ziemlich schwierig ist versucht man als singleplayer spiel 15
sekunden zu buffern willst du den input lag von 15 sekunden haben bis der buffer durch
ist oder was nee also beziehungsweise bis nee du hast kein input bis die andere seite
darauf reagieren kann das funktioniert bei musik zum teil und auch schon richtig aber
bei latency abhängigen sachen kannst du komplett vergessen
nee ich werde es mir angucken sollte mich wirklich der overwatch wahnsinn wieder packen
dann vielleicht aber sieht nicht so aus haben wir schon haben wir vor einer weile haben
wir tatsächlich pvz wieder ein bisschen gespielt für starcraft leute heißt pvz übrigens
was ganz was anderes als plants vs zombies wie sinnvoll ist es pearl zu lernen da gibt
es nein gar nicht sinnvoll wie kommst du auf pearl ja die letzten fünf minuten bevor du
reingekommen bist habe ich über das logitech handheld geredet und das ist jetzt kein schiebe
das war wirklich so wie wie wie kommst du auf pearl zur kahn an ich kann wie kommst
du auf wie kommst du auf pearl also weshalb was hat dich dazu gebracht dass du dir da
gedanken zu machst das wird mich interessieren was sagst du zu deinem elektroauto nach paar
wochen ich finde es immer noch nice ich habe auch letztens schon bei ikea kostenlos geladen
ohne was zu kaufen aber das ist zeitlich beschränkt mittlerweile aber ich war wenigstens im ikea
drin leute ich habe nicht einfach nur da gesessen ja weiß gar nicht ob das überhaupt noch
geht naja doch theoretisch müsste das funktionieren egal es ist beschränkt auf ich glaube 90
minuten mittlerweile also du kannst gar nicht dein auto vollladen aber ich war im ikea
und habe erst mal umsonst geladen off-topic die frage ist nicht off-topic also ich finde
es tatsächlich gut wenn man frag ruhig also meiner meinung nach ist pearl zu lernen heutzutage
relativ sinnlos es gibt sie gut so gut wie nix was aktuell noch in pearl entwickelt wird
das einzige was mir spontan einfällt das ist sicherlich nicht das größte pearl projekt
was es so gibt aber das einzige was mir spontan einfällt ist wie heißt dieses heim automatisierung
sie fem manche benutzen das ja noch dass es in pearl programmiert es sieht auch dementsprechend
aus kackel allah guckt euch an man war nagios in pearl nie nagios nicht in pearl nagios
ist in c du konntest du konntest nagios checks in pearl machen aber das konntest du in ziemlich
jeder sprache machen in den nagios war in c so ansonsten mir fällt nichts in pearl ein
und auch ganz ehrlich pearl ist eine sprache die ist nicht schön die macht aus meiner
sich kein bock zu programmieren die macht auch kein bock zu lernen also es gibt 2022
ich also ich sehe zumindest keinen gibt es keinen grund mehr pearl zu lernen und wenn
man nur pearl kann sollte man dringend mal gucken ob man nicht ein paar andere sachen
sich anschaut ne so viele grills wie beim agila gibt es natürlich nicht mit dem e auto
das stimmt schon ja eins vom insie modus leute ich weiß nicht ob ich es euch gezeigt habe
aber ich hab letztens vom finanzamt eine mahnung gekriegt guckt euch das mal an hier eins eins
eins vor insie modus übrigens es sind nicht es sind nicht 45.500 es sind 455 da kann man
erst mal bisschen geschockt sein wenn man das so sieht und nicht nicht den header sich
anschaut da kann man erst mal lesen 55.000 aber es sind 455 ich hab schlicht ergreifen
vergessen dass ich das überweisen muss ich wusste ich hab schlicht ergreifen vergessen
ich hab instant überwiesen danach weil die sind nervig wenn du nicht überweicht hab
instant überwiesen
auf der arbeit habe ich eine ducky one skyline die ist nice und die gibt es vielleicht auch
in plus switches was das ist richtig lost das ist das ist richtig lost alter ich meine
ich kann verstehen dass man pies nicht mag es gibt immer irgendwas was du in allem aussetzen
kannst es gibt auch sachen die ich an pies nicht mag aber trotzdem ich finde es an sich
eigentlich ganz nice aber ich kann verstehen dass jemand sagt ich kann es nicht ab aber
im gleichen atemzug dann pearl zu mögen das ist ja das eigentliche problem dass man pies
und kacke findet meinetwegen ok aber dass man dann im gleichen atemzug pearl gut finde
das ist wirklich lost
wie twitter client der nicht nervt mit login wie twitter das ist twitter plus ohne login
nerv kram so ok wo sind wir stehen geblieben leute also ich muss eigentlich nochmal von
vorne anfangen zu erzählen glaube ich was ich jetzt vorhabe also weil als ich angefangen
hab zu erzählen waren 100 leute da und das stream hat gerade angefangen das war vor 30
minuten jetzt habe ich alles mögliche erzählt und jetzt weiß keiner mehr wo wir eigentlich
stehen geblieben sind oder weiß noch jemand wo wir stehen geblieben sind ich ich fürchte
nicht ich auch nicht mehr mein mein mein gedächtnis sagt hier keck bei memory leak memory leak
genau tatsächlich sowohl im hirn als auch wir sind tatsächlich beim memory leak stehen
geblieben wobei es gar kein wirkliches memory leak gewesen ist zwar beim ram bedarf also
ich hatte euch die docker files gezeigt und das eigentliche problem war dass wobei jetzt
weiß ich wo ich war also jetzt weiß ich wo ich war also die leute haben sich beschwert
dass das addon nicht funktioniert ja der hat sich beschwert der hat sich beschwert und dann
kam raus ok das benutzt wohl einiges an ram und ich hab festgestellt mein addon und wie
gesagt das addon macht ein paar http requests das sendet ein paar http requests das addon
braucht 700 bis zu 750 mb ram 750 mb das läuft natürlich auch im kleinen raspberry
peinlich wenn dann auch ein bisschen mehr läuft und ich dachte erst mal ich hatte erst
mal im verdacht frage machen wir gleich ich hatte erst mal im verdacht dass es die amazon
library ist weil ich hatte da schon mal dass die dinger teilweise übelst ram fressen und
wenn man mal guckt nach dotnet aws libraries und und memory usage da gibt es viele reports
dass die dotnet libraries von amazon sehr großzügig sind was ram genehmigung angeht
ja war es aber gar nicht war es gar nicht wisst ihr was es gewesen ist wisst ihr was
die hohe ram auslastung verursacht hat das hier ich kann es euch zeigen das hier das
hier hat die hohe ram auslastung verursacht dass ich nämlich jedes mal ein komplettes
bild gemacht habe von diesem programm also sprich um das zu um das addon zu starten wurde
jemals jedes mal ein dotnet run gemacht der hat ein bild gestartet hat das ding gestattet
und hat bei dem bild ungefähr 600 mb gebraucht ich habe keine ahnung warum das so unglaublich
viel ram braucht aber es ist so das braucht wahrscheinlich gar nicht so viel ram aber
ich vermute mal dass ich das zum bilden einfach ordentlich viel ram genehmigt dass es nicht
so viel memory allocations machen muss beziehungsweise nicht so viel neue neue betriebssystem gibt
mir speicher während dem kompilieren beziehungsweise während dem bauen vom vom vom programm also
das ging rauf bis auf 750 mb ram usage und das hat das ging dann mit der zeit auch wieder
runter ja also wenn man das wenn man das addon eine weile hat laufen lassen ich habe sogar
mal garbage collector reingemacht in in der main loop dass es auf jeden fall immer aufgeräumt
wird da ging das immer weiter runter so bis auf bis auf 200 noch epis oder so also das
das das ging dann schon das problem war nur dass die leute hier aus diesem ticket halt
in raspberry pie haben mit 2 gigabyte und home assistant braucht schon 1,3 gigabyte
und die haben einfach nicht genug ram das war einfach out of memory also was musste
ich machen vielleicht gibt es ein parameter eventuell aber ich musste eh schon mal vor
längerer zeit hätte ich das eigentlich schon machen sollen also was habe ich gemacht wir
bauen jetzt das image nicht mehr bei den leuten auf ihrem home assistant sondern wir bauen
das image vorher und pushen es bei mir in die docker registry in die in die container
registry und wenn man sich das hier jetzt anguckt es gibt jetzt offizielle packages
offizielle container images für das addon die ich selbst gebaut habe und das einzige
was jetzt noch passiert wenn irgendjemand dieses addon installiert ist der macht einen pull
auf dieses container image je nach architektur und kann das starten und am endeffekt sind
es jetzt pass mal auf hier waren wir bei hier waren wir bei 6 bis 750 mb ram und mittlerweile
sind wir bei 115 mb ram also wir sind von 750 runter auf 115 auf x86 und auf 25 auf
arm also wir sind von 700 mb ram usage runter auf 25 oder eben auf 114 je nachdem auf welcher
platform und es mit der 114 könnte auch sein dass dotnet einfach nur etwas großzügiger
ist auf kisten mit mehr ram also ich müsste das mal ausprobieren wenn ich die x86 kiste
nehme mal eine vm oder so oder irgendein container den man den man beschränkt auf auf 2 gigabyte
ram können es durchaus sein dass die x86 variante auch weniger ram frisst ich denke
mal dotnet pre allocated einfach ein bisschen was dass es nachher schneller ist also wir
sind runter von 600 mb auf was sinnvolles so und seitdem siehe da funktioniert das addon
auch bei den leuten guck da hier it works ja funktioniert gut jetzt hat er irgendwelche
schmerzen mit seinen automations da wollte ich ihm noch helfen aber das ist nicht eigentlich
nicht das problem von dem addon ja irgendein anderer hat nämlich auch noch geschrieben
hier update fail nach dem addon ja nach dem update kann ich verstehen weil das lokale bild
umgestellt wurde auf prebuilt images so soweit so gut und jetzt kommen wir zu dem was wir
heute machen bzw was man soll mal angucken wie erstellt man dann dieses image hier aktuell
habe ich das einfach auf die naheliegendste art und weise gemacht dieses image zu erstellen
das ist aber nicht sonderlich schön und auch nicht automatisch da muss man an viele sachen
denken ich muss denken dass das die versionsnummer hoch zu zählen in der in dem jammel feil
hier drinnen ich hier drinnen ich muss da denken die versionsnummer hier hoch zu zählen
ich muss daran denken die richtige architektur anzugeben beim image und ich muss das bauen
so folgendermaßen funktioniert es aktuell diese images zu erstellen das funktioniert
nicht reproduzierbar das ist das erste problem also ich zeige euch mal das bildscript ist
ganz furchtbar billig wie gesagt das ist auch nicht schön das ist einfach nur dass es
funktioniert dass ich das memory usage fixen konnte also der baut erst mal das programm
lokal bei mir auf dem rechner also sprich es kommt immer was anderes raus je nach dem
welche dotnet version ich gerade installiert habe und das ist ja das was du bei irgendwelchen
builds als letztes haben willst dass es abhängig ist von dem was du bei dir lokal gerade zufälliger
weise auf dem rechner installiert hast weil vielleicht mache ich ein upgrade auf dotnet
8 wenn es rauskommt oder auf beta von dotnet 8 und dann klappt irgendwas nicht und ja keine
ahnung das ist auf jeden fall nicht schön also der baut das programm einmal einmal
für x86 und einmal für arm und danach das mit koemo kann man sich kann man sich sparen
und danach startet er den offiziellen home assistant docker bilder den man eigentlich
gar nicht braucht wenn man es mal genau nimmt und der baut dann da draus in container und
upload das hier in die registry ne noch keine github actions wie gesagt ich habe das gemacht
dass es einfach schnell geht das also zu dem zeit also nicht schnell in der durchführung
sondern schnell im erstellen also dass ich den kram schnell uploaden konnte dass ihnen
dass das das memory usage gefixt wurde und dann gibt es halt diese images so und was
ich mir jetzt überlegt habe ist wir könnten das ganze in github actions machen das hat
dann auch den vorteil dass man das irgendwie reproduzierbar machen könnte ich weil man
könnte das auch lokal reproduzierbar machen also das einfachste was mir so einfallen würde
wäre folgendes das hier dieses wir bilden das mit dem lokalen dotnet würde ich ersetzen
durch irgendeinen dotnet container mit einem tag wird das bilden und dann halt die anwendung
in irgendeinem verzeichnis zwischenspeichern und dann das hier bauen lassen das würde
wahrscheinlich auch funktionieren aber schön ist was anderes so jetzt muss ich euch noch
das run script zeigen das ist nämlich auch ein bisschen unschön naja geht eigentlich
warum funktioniert das sekunde ich habe glaube ich misst erzählen im dockerfall genau also
das dockerfall muss noch an muss er noch angepasst werden dass er das erkennt dass diese images
für dieses repo sind ja genau nach dem bild muss er halt gucken dass für die jeweilige
architektur das bild rauskopiert wird in das image das ist alles nicht so schön ja multidokker
falls eines der sache wie man das lösen kann bzw in dem fall nicht so ganz weil das funktioniert
an der stelle alleine nicht weil moment lass mal überlegen was war das hier das funktioniert
an der stelle nicht weil diese home assistant add-on bilder nicht mit multistage docker
falls klarkommt aber multistage bild ist das sinnigste was du machen kannst ja da hast
du recht am besten der bild x zu verwenden weil dann könnte ich automatisch x86 und
arm images raushauen das wäre tatsächlich am besten es gibt leider ein paar probleme
weshalb alles nicht so richtig funktioniert so und ich überlege gerade ob ich euch so
mal ein paar highlights ich habe ja im vorfeld schon ein bisschen nachgeforscht erzähle
oder ob wir einfach anfangen und ich tu dann so als wüsste ich es nicht und dann fällt
das auf während dem stream ich erzähle euch mal was noch ein paar sachen dazu die man
machen kann die aber mehr oder weniger naja nicht richtig funktionieren soll ich muss
euch eine frage beantworten was war hier doch wo denn hier also ich habe doch letztens gesagt
dass der server so langsam reagiert mein kollege an 105 repair gestartet aber ja das erklärt
natürlich oder das wird natürlich erklärt warum das so langsam gewesen ist während dem
repair das rate 5 noch besonders zu belasten ist eh keine gute idee weil rate 5 ist eh
schon immer so ein bisschen jolo rate es ist nicht ganz so krass wie rate 0 in der beziehung
ja aber rate 5 ist je nachdem wie groß die platten sind und wie viele platten das nächste
an jolo rate was du machen kannst wenn du nicht rate 0 machen willst weil bei einem
rate 5 chat die fachinformatiker abschlussprüfung rate 5 wie viel platten sind mindestens notwendig
dafür und wie viel platten dürfen kaputt gehen 3 das ist richtig so sieht es aus genau
also man braucht mindestens drei platten und eine darf kaputt gehen die sache ist jetzt
die man braucht meistens macht man nur mit drei platten das heißt aber nicht dass man
das nur mit drei platten machen kann man braucht mindestens drei platten das heißt im endeffekt
auch wenn man jetzt rate 5 nimmt und macht das mit fünf oder sechs platten oder auch
schon mit vier platten und wenn das große platten sind und wenn das dann vielleicht
auch nicht die allerdolsten platten sind dann ist die chance dass das rate bei einem rebuild
kaputt geht relativ hoch und zwar deshalb weil du normalerweise gar nichts von merkst
wenn irgendwo was kaputt ist an den platten aber bei dem rebuild musst du von beiden platten
komplett die parity informationen lesen also sprich wenn irgendwie auch nur eine der anderen
platten einen kleinen knackzweck hat dann fällt das rebuild und im schlimmen fall im
blöden fall ist dein rate komplett im arsch also rate 5 ist meiner meinung nach mindestens
drei platten und sollten auch höchstens meinetwegen vielleicht vier aber ganz ehrlich mehr
als drei platten würde ich nicht nehmen es gibt sogar tatsächlich ein jetzt habe ich
chat gelesen habe vergessen was ich sagen wollte lull was habe ich gerade gesagt so
rate 5 drei platten genau man sollte es mit höchstens mit höchstens höchstens drei
platten machen es gibt sogar genau zweit wieder es gibt sogar ein ganz nice ist recht recht
ein tool ich weiß nicht ob ich das jetzt finde rate calculator oder sowas war das das hier
ne alter was das für eine seite monka es das ist nicht das meine ich nicht error error
calculator ja sowas sowas was soll der hintergrund kann man hinter konnte ich einfach weglassen
da kann man zum beispiel sagen mit 5 machen trieb sei es 10 terabyte namen wir auf trieb
6 so oder man kann sagen hier drei guck mal moment das kann jetzt sein das erscheint
mir dann doch moment den müssen wir glaube ich noch ein bisschen hoch machen ich glaube
so beschissen sind die meisten platten gar nicht mehr dass es 10 hoch 14 sind was haben
die normalerweise nehmen wir mal so eine 10 terabyte sie geht ein wolf oder ist es sowas
hatten die fehler rate error wir haben wir heißen der krempel noch mal stats data sheet
genau error 10 hoch seht ihr irgendwas hier 10 hoch 10 auf 15 10 auf 15 ok schon besser
schon besser also guck mal also das passt ganz gut also wir haben ein 5 mit 10 terabyte
platten mit an record an recoverable read error rate von 10 auf 15 mit drei platten
oder sind wir nur bei 85 ganz ehrlich das kommt mir tatsächlich auch ein bisschen bisschen
niedrig vor aber sag mal du hast 15 prozent mit so diesen 08 15 platten ja du hast schon
eine chance von 15 prozent dass das ding nicht ordentlich dass dein rate quasi verreckt
so und jetzt pass mal auf machen wir auf vier platten oder macht man gar auf sechs platten
also bei sechs platten hast du schon eine chance von einem drittel dass dein rate nicht
mehr ordentlich rebuilden kann und wenn du pech hast steigt dir dann die platte von der
du rebuilden willst auch geradeaus weil sie der meinung ist oh je wir haben jetzt aber
ganz schön viele read errors gehabt also rate 5 ist wirklich nicht ohne rate 6 ist
viel viel besser also weil es sind zwei platten rate 6 ist was das angeht deutlich deutlich
besser wobei es bei dieser größe auch einfach so mit drei und vier platten kann man damit
leben aber drei platten rate 6 funktioniert überhaupt nicht richtig lull rate 6 musste
eigentlich mit fünf mal also sinnigerweise mit fünf drei platten zum benutzen rate 6
ist genau das gleiche wie rate 5 nur dass du zwei parity platten verwendest es ist exakt
das gleiche wie rate 5 nur dass du die parity halt doppelt speichert und dementsprechend
brauchst du halt also zwei platten die kaputt gehen können so rum du speichert die parities
doppelt das heißt du brauchst natürlich auch mehr speicher dafür das heißt du verlierst
bei rate 6 zwei platten für parity versus eine bei rate 5 ja also eigentlich musst
es mit fünf platten machen sonst ist es relativ sinnlos deswegen sind wir nochmal dabei dass
rate nichts taugt für backup der einzige sinn von rate ist das kann man nicht oft genug
sagen ich bin mir nicht sicher ob wir heute noch zu github actions kommen bei dem tempo
wie ich bin fast eine stunde online und nichts gemacht aber gut es ist ja auch irgendwo devops
tv deswegen brauchen wir einen backup der einzige sinn von rate ist eigentlich verfügbarkeit
nicht datensicherheit oder wie nennt man es jetzt sicherheit das hört sich jetzt so
nach security zeug an nee also verfügbarkeit versus halt verlust verlust ja also rate 6
also rate ist nicht versus datenverlust ist nicht gut für daten also gegen datenverlust
sondern gut für verfügbarkeit man kann sich das im endeffekt so vorstellen in rate 6
ist ungefähr das was man auch erreichen will wenn man ein zweites netzteil einbaut du willst
das ding verfügbar halten du hast ein zweites netzteil oder hast du einen zweiten stromanschluss
an der kiste einfach aus dem grund wenn du mal eine seite verreckt so hast du es bei
einem rate 6 auch wenn du mal eine platte verreckt kannst du rebuilden und gut ist wohin
gegen dich rate nicht schützt ist datenverlust datenverlust kann ja auftreten nicht nur
beim kaputt gehen einer platte sondern auch weil man blödsinn macht zum beispiel klassisches
beispiel was total oft vorkommt wo wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal früher oder später wo jeder
wahrscheinlich die probleme hatte oder sie früher oder später haben wird wenn ihr beispielsweise
dropbox verwendet oder nex cloud verwendet oder irgendeinen zynk verwendet und ihr löscht
beispielsweise daten auf der einen seite nein zfs schützt dich in dem fall absolut
auch gar nicht vor datenverlust zfs schützt dich vor datenverlust wenn du kaputtes sektor
oder sowas auf der festplatte hast und dann auch so dass du es merkst zfs kann er nicht
auf magische art und weise die platte reparieren du merkst das so aber wo es dich nicht davor
schützt ist wenn du zum beispiel da wenn du snapshots natürlich wenn du snapshots machst
dann ist es wieder was anderes aber einen snapshots geht ja auch schon eher in richtung
back up also ich meine einen snapshots ist quasi die high iq variante von ersynch auf
eine zweite platte aber jeder hat es wahrscheinlich schon mal gehabt wenn ihr irgendwie nen zynk
habt zwischen zwei rechnern und er löscht auf der einen seite aus versehen was dann
zynkt sich quasi das gelöschte auf den anderen rüber und auf beiden seiten ist der ordner
weg so ähnlich kann euch das bei rate natürlich auch passieren also ihr geht auf euren auf
euren samba share oder auf euren wie heißt das ding auf deutsch ne wie heißt das ding
auf eurer windows datei freigabe netzwerk ordner freigabe oder so ähnlich also ihr
geht auf euren samba share und löscht aus versehen das falsche verzeichnis und habt den
papier kommt nicht an dann ist es weg egal ob rate oder nicht also dagegen bringt rate
nix das einzige was euch dann rettet ist ihr habt einen back up oder ihr habt einen snapshots
gemacht aber das läuft ja aufs gleiche raus also es ist nicht die rate funktionalität
die euch schützt davor und das schützt einen auch zfs nicht davor ich mein was soll zfs
dagegen machen das ist ja ein ist aber absichtlich ausgelöster vorgang löschen löscht den
ordner ja dann ist er fort wenn du einen snapshot hast dann ist es was anderes ja und rate
ist nur dafür gedacht dass es verfügbar verfügbar bleibt bei plattenausfall und wenn ihr nämlich
aus versehen den falschen ordner löscht dann ist das rate ja weiterhin verfügbar aber
die daten sind trotzdem weg oder genau ja genau wenn du zum beispiel irgendwelche verschlüsselungsgeschichten
dir eingefangen hast weil es weder irgendeiner nicht lassen konnte auf sein email anhand
zu klicken dann hast du auch gelippen da bringt ja auch nur ein back up was bzw snapshots
die daten sind also immer gleich auf den anderen platten ja aber wenn ich sie lösche ich meine
der kann ja schlecht der kann ja schlecht einfach mal auf gut glück ein paar daten
dalassen oder wie meinst du das ich meine wenn ich sage ich will die daten löschen
dann sind die weg außer halt ich habe snapshot gemacht zfs kann ja schlecht sagen ah vielleicht
lösche ich mal ein paar nicht also da wäre ja so die platten untereinander inkonsistent
wenn auf der einen noch was da wäre und auf der anderen nicht also das ist wirklich ding
was viele verkehrt machen die denken sich ja wir machen in rate 5 und sind für alles
gewappnet und da sieht man nein ist man nicht erstens in rate 5 geht relativ schnell kaputt
bei einem rebuild bzw rebuild funktioniert nicht mehr richtig oder aber ups ich habe
mich verklickt und was gelöscht und dagegen hilft dir halt kein rate dagegen hilft dir
nur brain oder backups bzw snapshots machen jetzt müssen wir aber mal langsam weitermachen
sonst wird das heute echt nichts mehr der last rewrite das werde ich nie machen
ja gut electron devs interessiert das nicht da ist es ja ein feature dass das ding 700
mb ram verbraucht überlegt euch mal eine elektron an wenn ihr nicht 700 mb ram verbraucht da
wird ja jeder denken die ist kaputt und wer will anwendungen verteilen von denen man denkt
sie sind kaputt
kann man machen wir können auch github actions verwenden ok so falls ihr irgendwelche fragen
überlesen habt schreibt einfach noch mal in chat so was so doch das ist das ist der
typische frage die in der abschlussprüfung kommen kann leute ich muss ich muss ich muss
ich muss ich mal kurz was anders erzählen einfach dass ihr seht was was für ein ein
netter kerl ich bin ja und zwar mich hat fast auf verwandtschaftsverhältnisse um um drei
ecken wieder er mich hat eine freundin von meiner mutter angerufen dass der lebensgefährte
von ihrer tochter habe ich auch gedacht alter was interessieren mich diese leute geht mir
nicht auf den sack gerade eine umschulung zum fachinformatiker macht und dennoch eine
praktikum stelle sucht ob ich nicht was kennen würde und ich habe mir eigentlich so gedacht
alter leute lasst mich in ruhe geht mir nicht auf den keks mann aber was habe ich gemacht
ich habe bei uns gefragt wie es aussieht mit praktikumsplätzen und wahrscheinlich kriegt
kann er bei uns ein praktikumsplatz kriegen eigentlich habe ich überhaupt keinen bock
drauf gehabt ich habe das trotzdem gemacht würdest du im öffentlichen dienst aber die
kohle stimmt und die arbeitsbedingungen ist mir das ja warum nicht wenn du musst wenn
du da macht eine umschulung zum fachinformatiker das ist quasi bevor du abschlussprüfung machen
kannst wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe von ihm da musst du irgendwie ein praktikum
machen und oder vielleicht vor der zwischendurch keine ahnung und muss du praktikum machen
ich glaube von acht monaten und nur dann kannst du die irgendwie erfolgreich abschließen
irgendwie so ist das ja der macht eine umschulung zum fisi wusste bis dahin gar nicht dass
sowas gibt was macht denn der hr docker bilder lässt sich das nicht umgehen jemand normal
multistage bild macht das als base push ja das könnte vielleicht funktionieren normalerweise
möchte er doch das könnte wahrscheinlich doch du hast recht es könnte wahrscheinlich
funktionieren normalerweise schreibt man gar kein image rein in den ha in den home assistant
bilder sondern der nimmt automatisch das richtige image passend zur architektur das musst du
dann nicht selbst machen das macht das sucht er für dich raus und search and replace das
schon so dass man es nicht machen muss das ist halt dafür gemacht dass die einstiegshürde
um addons zu erstellen einfacher ist dass du den leuten sagen kannst hier copy paste
das in dein terminal upload das addon und fertig ist doch das müsste wahrscheinlich gehen was
du sagst dass man zuerst in bildstab macht und das base image dann verwendet irgendwie
wahrscheinlich geht das wahrscheinlich geht das moin hast du ideen fürs automatische
patchen von apps das automatische patchen patchen von willst du irgendwie die serien
serial ab seriennummer abfrage umgehen oder oder was wird was für tos tos geschichten
sollen das wieder werden hier ach ich sollte weiterlesen du meinst updaten du meinst updaten
jetzt habe ich es gecheckt ich hätte ich hätte in zweit die zweite hälfte des satzes
mal lesen sollen ich habe an patchen gedacht du willst automatisch ich dachte du willst
die neueste version haben und immer automatisch in den crack installieren oder so so nach dem
motto sobald ich neues paket runter lade soll es gekrackt werden oder sowas in der
richtung ok ja win get gibt's win get ist tatsächlich für windows die beste die beste
lösung wenn man sowas halbwegs offizielles haben will was ich persönlich gerne benutze
ist das hier scoop allerdings ist das eher für entwicklungs für entwickler tools hier
guck das das das finde ich persönlich ganz nice da hab da habe ich dann so zeug drüber
installiert wie youtube downloads vlc package manager und kram ja ich persönlich mag für
entwickler tools scoop lieber einfach als kommando zeilen tool ist was sich ordentlich
bedienen lässt im vergleich zu win get ich denke über kurz oder lang wird es die bessere
auswahl in win get geben schokolade hier das habe ich mal verwendet vor zig zig jahren
und da musste man für alles noch admin berechtigung immer eintippen das war doof ich denke mal
über kurz oder lang mit win get das werden mit den größten größten aber win get ist
ziemlich ja müll also die meisten dieser tools sind unter windows relativ müllig relativ
relativ kacke weil es unter windows einfach so einen unglaublichen wildwuchs an installern
gibt du hast ja bis heute noch installer oder sachen die win get nur installieren kann aber
nicht mehr ordentlich deinstallieren und solche geschichten das ist ganz ganz eklig sachen
die win get nicht installieren kann ohne dass du doch noch ein paar mal im installer klicken
musst also es ist halt einfach 30 jahre wildwuchs unter windows was das angeht wir hatten einen
kunde dem ist das rate 6 gecrasht ja das wir haben es ja gerade ausgerechnet das kann schon
mal passieren dann hat er das auf ein 18 terabyte hd platte retten lassen und darauf weiter
gearbeitet er gut er wartet halt bis die 18 terabyte platte dann auch krascht wobei ganz
ehrlich die idee war schnell noch so schnell wie es irgendwie geht noch mal einen dampf
ziehen ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so verkehrt solange das noch irgendwie funktioniert
ja wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss so richtig so richtig halte ich mich da auch nicht dran
wahrscheinlich hält sich keiner so richtig dran chat wer weiß was die 321 regel ist
also da geht es unter anderem um kopien von datalen und backups und locations wo das gespeichert
ist und sowas also damit ist folgendes damit ist folgendes gemeint du solltest dreimal
die datei haben du solltest streber ja genau du solltest dreimal die datei lokal haben
liegen haben du solltest zwei warte mal jetzt krieg ich es auch gar nicht mehr zusammen
du solltest zumindest ein oft seit backup haben die war das dreimal die datei liegen
haben zwei backups haben und ein oft seit backup haben irgendwie so ich krieg es auch
gar nicht mehr richtig zusammen 2321 regel backups gucken wir mal drei kopien sollst
du haben die kopien auf zwei verschiedene speichermedien gesparte kopien an einem extra
standort ja gut stimmt ja ungefähr was ich gesagt habe oft seit backup ist so ein ding
das vernachlässige ich ein bisschen und die datei dreimal kopieren ist auch ein bisschen
overkill oder dreimal quasi speicherplatz dafür verschwenden da muss es ja nicht übertreiben
also man kann da auch 211 oder so draus machen beziehungsweise 211 geht nicht 221 oder 220
es ist alles alle mal besser als einfach nur ein raid zu haben und hoffen dass nie was
passiert oder 210 es ist alles besser als eine als eine platte zu haben die dann verreckt
und alles ist weg so sieht es aus endlich mal wenn immer die frage kommt max was kannst
du besonders gut nix machen und schwätzen sieht man hier im stream immer wieder
wie liest ihr eure software in der firma kommt drauf an welche wir haben einen ganz ganz
riesen wild wuchs an software gehen wir mal von unserer von unserem java kram aus ja also
wie gesagt wir haben ganz ganz viel unterschiedliches zeug auf ganz ganz unterschiedlich vielen
plattformen wir haben software die wird komplett erstes service in der cloud gehostet wir haben
software die ist in dem azure kubernetes cluster wir haben azure vms wo sachen drauf sind
wir haben ganz viel eingekaufte software wir haben selbst programmierte java software selbst
programmierte kobold software wir haben selbst programmiertes node js gedöns also es ist
wirklich ganz ganz unterschiedlich gehen wir mal von unserem also gehen wir mal von
den wichtigsten sachen aus das ist in der regel java software und die ist dafür da
dass der außendienst also falls ihr mal von irgendeiner bank ein von euch zu euch heim
bestellt und er euch beraten soll zu irgendwas was ihr wahrscheinlich nicht braucht dann
benutzt er in ordentliche software benutzen dafür für vertragsabwicklung und und solche
geschichten und das ist so quasi mit das wichtigste was es gibt neben ist aber mal neben
der ganzen kobold berechnungsgeschichte da darf natürlich gar nichts stimmt gar nichts
schiefgehen so und das java zeug das ist muss man sagen tatsächlich sehr oldschool mäßig
noch es gibt paar mal im monat um genau zu sein einmal im monat pro entf wie nennt man
das pro pro entwicklung status pro entwicklung stage gibt es dann quasi einen also gibt dann
beispielsweise einen termin wo es neue versionen gibt für testumgebung gibt beispielsweise
einen termin wo es neue versionen gibt dann für die für die live system das passiert
einmal im monat nachts um 23 ne das stimmt gerade nachts um ein uhr bis sechs uhr morgens
einmal im monat und das ist ganz klassisch da gibt es irgendwo einen server wo wie heißt
das wie heißt das bei java wo man bild bilds drauf speichert maven ist das maven kann
das sein oder nexus nexus oder maven ich kenne mich ich kenne mich kenne mich mit mit java
zeug nicht aus also es gibt irgendwo so einen java repo wo deine ganzen gebildeten files
und gedöns und zeug rumliegen und dann wird das hin scp einmal im monat das zeug ist halt
auch schon irgendwann ursprünglich mal entstanden 1995 oder so und da hat sich nie was dran geändert
der rest ist tatsächlich deutlich moderner aber so diese klassische java ist old school
as fuck das wird das wird dann einmal im monat um ein uhr nachts hin scp wobei das hin scp
tatsächlich mit irgendeinem automatisierungsverfahren funktioniert also vielleicht klickt dann
einer noch in irgendeinem jankins oder so auf auf deploy ich keine ahnung ich hab das
noch nie gesehen zumindest habe ich gesehen wo ich auch schon mal kecken musste bei einem
entwickler habe ich das gesehen bei uns damit die wissen auf welchen server sie was schieben
müssen haben die irgendwie ein xml feil ein xml feil wo irgendwie ich krieg sie mir so
genau zusammen die haben ein xml feil wo irgendwie gemapt ist ihre application namen zu server
namen und wenn sie dann sagen sie wollen jetzt keine ahnung hier base application xy deployen
dann haben sie irgendwie den deploy tool was wahrscheinlich klicken sie im jankins auf
ein knöpfchen oder so und er guckt dann im xml nach wo muss denn das hin und dann ganz
wirres zeug ganz wirres zeug cofax dankeschön für den für 13 monat subscription ganz wirres
zeug also das ist wirklich da kommst du dir vor wie in der steinzeit wenn du dir anguckst
wie unser java zeug deployt wird aber sie sind auf einem guten weg weil an vielen stellen
ist schon die sachen umgestellt auf etwas modernere infrastruktur und sei es nur dass
das nicht mal alles von hand gemacht wird und vieles und gerade und gerade vieles neue
also irgendwelche neuen berechnungs sachen und sowas das läuft tatsächlich alles kontinuerisiert
mittlerweile und das alte zeug gestaltet sich halt ein bisschen schwierig zum umziehen das
ist dann so wir hatten das programmiert achtertüp der ist schon seit fünf jahren nicht mehr
in der firma oder der ist schon gestorben vor zwei jahren oder so wir hatten letztens
allen herz kein kein kein witz ich überlege gerade was da kaputt war ich kriege irgendwas
IBM großrechner technisches und irgendwas wurde nicht richtig verarbeitet ich kann es
euch nicht genau sagen ich krieg es nicht mal zusammen was es war zumindest irgendwas
was noch auf einem IBM mainframe läuft so und da war ich in so einem entstörungsmeeting
und da haben die allen ernstes jetzt haltet euch vielleicht da haben die allen ernstes
geguckt ok wir hatten davon ahnung wer könnte wer könnte uns denn was dazu sagen sondern
haben sie dann her ich denke mir jetzt mal ein name aus ja da haben sie an herr müller
gefunden naja herr müller hat es mal irgendwie gemacht vor sieben jahren oder so ja kriegen
wir den kriegen wir den irgendwie noch ist er noch da ne der ist nicht mehr da ja wo
ist er denn jetzt und da kam dann raus der typ ist halt in rente der typ ist in rente
und dann haben die ungelogen leute die haben dann jemand gesucht der noch raus kriegen
kann wie man herr müller erreicht und die haben den angerufen in der rente also daheim
irgend so ein opa der mal kobold zeug programmiert hat der seit sieben jahren oder so in rente
ist oder oder oder seit fünf das hat funktioniert das hat ein bisschen gedauert bis sie das
raus gekriegt haben und ich weiß gar nicht ob der sich das überhaupt hat bezahlen lassen
wahrscheinlich nicht die haben das aber auch geschickt gemacht die haben das auch wirklich
die haben das wirklich big brain gemacht die hatten nämlich noch einen der kannte den
und den haben die dann quasi anrufen lassen so nach dem motto hallo karl wie gehts lange
nicht gehört sag mal du hast doch damals dieses verarbeitungs ding auf dem großrechner programmiert
kannst du dich daran erinnern als wir damals lochkarten gestanzt haben so und das hat funktioniert
der war dann auf einmal im call drin oder hat was zu erklärt
was ist denn das ibb keine ahnung wie groß ist unsere IT abteilung
das kann ich dir aus dem stehgreif gar nicht also es ist so viel dass ich dir nicht aus
dem stehgreif sagen kann es gibt ja mehrere IT abteilungen es gibt ja gar nicht nur eine
es gibt mindestens drei es gibt infrastruktur und es gibt anwendungsentwicklung ich hab
das organigramm jetzt nicht im kopf aber ich glaube es gibt drei es kann nee leute
es gibt vier mittlerweile es gibt sogar vier IT abteilungen bei uns es gibt frag mich nicht
cloud services und outsourcing gedöns es gibt anwendungsentwicklung es gibt so infrastruktur
administration und es gibt es gibt es noch support natürlich hab ich ganz vergessen
support gibt auch noch es gibt vier IT abteilungen und wie viele leute da sind ich kann es dir
wirklich nicht sagen also wenn ich jetzt raten müsste keine ahnung 600 oder so das ist
jetzt aber einfach nur mal so ins blaue ich hab keine ahnung es ist auf jeden fall nicht
wenig es ist nicht riesen riesen riesen groß wie jetzt jetzt irgendwie nicht nicht microsoft
oder sap oder sonst was es ist aber relativ groß habt ihr noch einen mainframe ja wir
haben wir haben nicht nur einen mainframe wir haben zwei mainframes und ich habe auch gelernt
dass du den mainframe also ich zeige euch mal wie sowas aussieht weil die es noch nicht
gesehen haben sowas ja genau sowas da in der richtung ist das dass du den bei dir im rechenzentrum
stehen hast du den bezahlen darfst du den aber nicht benutzen darfst wie du willst das
ding gehört immer noch IBM und du musst die rechenzeit darauf bezahlen muss man sich
mal vorstellen was du hast du hast das ding gekauft für 300.000 euro oder so du betreibst
das bei dir im rechenzentrum aber wenn du was drauf berechnen willst koste dich das
du hast visualcobalt.net
haben die da irgendwie was was was den rechner abends abschaltet oder was oder geht geht
das licht aus um 22 uhr und der rechner mit
nächstes ist das aha siehst du mal da lernt man noch was über java
ja cobalt entwickler werden tatsächlich immer noch gesucht im im gegensatz zu pearl
also cobalt hat pearl überlebt und wird es auch weiterhin ne ne nix mit os 2 ich glaube
unser mainframe läuft aktuell tatsächlich sogar mit linux
ich bin mir nicht sicher es gibt ja irgendwie dieses dieses dieses offizielle zos und linux
kannst du mittlerweile drauf laufen lassen auch ich glaube das meiste läuft mittlerweile
mit linux auf dem mainframe ja das das problem haben sie alle
das wird das bei mir heißt das java genauso wie es gif heißt und und und jason heißt
jason und nicht jason oder wie der typ das letztes erzählt hat
das einzige wo ich mich nicht entscheiden kann ist ob china oder china ist deswegen sind
das die china chinesen
ja das erzählen die bei uns auch laufen das das ding wird nie weg sein ich glaube nicht
dass ich das noch erleben werde dass der mainframe weg ist
ok also nehmen wir mal einen neuen anlauf ich habe euch jetzt ja alles erzählt was das
problem war wir hatten hohe ramauslastung und deswegen habe ich das gefixt und habe
es als eigenes image gemacht so und jetzt bin ich dabei wie man das image am besten
bilden kann und in die container registry pushen ich habe mir folgendes überlegt was
ich mal ausprobieren wollte das hat nämlich nur am rande was mit diesem addon zu tun und
zwar ich habe mir folgendes ich habe mir folgendes überlegt wäre es nicht nice wenn man also
wenn der chat funktionieren würde vielleicht wäre auch gut wäre es nicht nice wenn man
auf seinem desktop ein package bauen könnte für den raspberry pi das geht ja prinzipiell
du kannst ja also gibt ja verschiedene varianten wie man das machen kann wenn es ein c programm
ist kannst du es cross compile zu haben das ist relativ einfach aber man kann auch mit
qemo arm auf x86 emulieren so wenn man docker bild x verwendet dann macht das das standardmäßig
schon also ich zeige ich zeige euch das mal ich mache mal so ein mini mini docker feil
haben hier mk dir kecke beste ordner da weiß ich immer wieder genau was sache ist wenn
ich mir das angucke irgendwie hier machen wir auf ja wir trusten u feil docker feil lehn
ich weiß immer richtig schreibt docker feil from debian keine ahnung debian bull bulls
eye das ist aktuelle glaube schon ja was was was wollen wir da irgendwas drinne machen
es reicht eigentlich schon mehr müssen wir nicht mal minimal docker feil ja mit minimal
stocker feil so und jetzt und jetzt kann man eigentlich oder brauche ich noch ein run
nicht brauche kein run ich glaube das bildet auch so können wir mal ausbilden docker bild
als pullt er erstmal das debian image funktioniert wunderbar so was man jetzt machen kann ist
docker bild x kann man sagen docker bild bild x ach scheiße man docker bild x bild was
meine güte genau so ja das kannst du machen so und was da standardmäßig macht ist der
baut jetzt dieses image für mehrere plattformen man kann sagen baumal eins ich zeige euch dann
auch wie das funktioniert baumal im image ihr seht es nämlich gleich wenn ich hier
wenn ich hier top anschmeiße baumal für plattform auf wie war diese wie war diese schreibweise
arm 7 v 2 ne arm 7 arm 32 7 ah meine güte docker bild x ne ich will nicht verarmen serious
marks der hat's wieder der weiß es der weiß linux arm v7 genau so und was der jetzt macht
ist folgendes der kann jetzt ausarbeit dort net da funktioniert nicht so viel spoiler ich
schon mal der kann jetzt eine arm cpu also eine arm cpu emulieren und das image dafür
bauen meine güte alter wer kann sich das alles aus dem kopf merken hier plattform es ist
relativ sicher plattform plattform multi plattform images minus minus plattform ja was und was
ist da jetzt so viel anders zu dem was ich gemacht habe
ne das ist egal was ach es ist einfach so es ist ohne das gleich so rum es ist ok so und
jetzt seht ihr werdet gleich sehen was der meine fresse warum geht das nicht warum ist
was wo ist der letztes problem schon wieder
den falschen ordner das geht ich hab ich hab das letztes das ist eigentlich mein docker
zu alt das creating muss man nicht machen hat normalerweise im default default docker
bild x ls mein docker bild x ist not
was ist das aktuelle docker release
ich frage wie die wikipedia wissen das ich habe das aktuellste ich hab das vor zwei tagen
oder so erst gemacht
muss man das vielleicht vorher machen
das sein dass mein docker ziemlich kaputt ist ich bin noch in der dockergruppe drinne
das muss man normalerweise nicht als root machen wenn man eine dockergruppe drin ist ist es
so gut wie root ok das funktioniert schon mal richtig richtig nice alles ja aber mit
judo ist das ist mein was zum
ok bild x installing excellent ok installing
nein ich will es nicht inside eines docker files machen ich will es auf meinem host haben
oder manual down manual down ich hab ich hab das vor zwei tagen erst gemacht mit was
andere da muss ich doch nichts da oder bin ich jetzt total wird anscheinend
der monster wirklich das plug in habe ich das vielleicht automatisch gemacht ohne dass
ich das realisiert habe
vielleicht hatte ich schon mal irgendwann installiert ok plattform so jetzt aber bäm
also ihr seht was denn auch was der jetzt macht gleich
der macht ja nichts ich ok ich muss ich muss in dockerfile erstmal irgendwas machen einfach
nur das image ziehen bringt mir nichts
wir können jetzt das install
ich will einfach dass irgendwas passiert
wie gesagt wir brauchen das nicht weil es gibt ein fertiges image für das dotnet zeug
wie ging das köln minus z ja da köln geben excellent genau das brauchen wir
erstmal schön köln rein copy pasten
plus c 7.2 so run
ich weiß woran es liegt leute ich weiß woran es liegt ich habe doch ein köln update gemacht
ich muss erst mal rebooten wenn du köln update gemacht das ist doch
immer kaputt du musst das mal rebooten
was ist es deswegen geht das nicht das ist das jahres linux des tops
so jetzt aber
wo war man jetzt in welchem or tem temp keckel sind wir gefaßt tem keckel alles klar so
bild ok und jetzt jetzt kann ich endlich zeigen was
ich euch zeigen wollte wenn ich jetzt bilden lasse nein auch nicht sudo wir brauchen eigentlich
wir müssen es gar nicht als sudo machen
sollte er nicht standardmäßig jetzt rüber switchen auf
ach nee jetzt jetzt muss ich ja noch die ganzen anderen sachen setzen dass es funktioniert
zumindest worauf ich eigentlich raus will ist es hat keinen sinn weil es funktioniert
eh nicht worauf ich raus will ist man kann mit qemo ein arm cpu emulieren dass der das
container image bauen kann installiert doch einfach zsh und dann was genau soll das bringen
bei diesem problem jetzt
so wo sind wir jetzt hier bei multi multiplatform builds gewesen genau
docker bild xls kann man irgendwie machen dann sieht man die bilder ja das ist
ach da ist gar kein gar keiner installiert für
ich hab kein qemo drauf kann das sein
ich hab gar kein qemo drauf dann kann das auch dann funktionieren
ohne qemo tut sich da nix
ich könnte qemo installieren in einem docker container der dann den docker container baut
ist das würde funktionieren was bei checking f ist immer was zum
ok also das da muss ich installieren alles klar so was haben wir jetzt arm 64 arm v7
ja das sieht besser aus ok alles klar
ok so und jetzt bild
das kann überhaupt nicht fertig sein
genau das sollte er jetzt dort nicht extrahieren jetzt
genau das sollte der jetzt da machen
ne ne er muss was ausführen was
warum macht er das jetzt denn denn ich
ach cashed run
ne ne du sollst da nix cashen
aber selbst dann ok da wir machen einfach dass der run nicht mehr gecasht werden kann
echo 1 2 3 so
das geht viel zu schnell
da ist bestimmt kein ok update das dauert ein bisschen wenigstens
so jetzt sieht man es hier guck
der führt qemo aus und das braucht ordentlich an cpu last also der emuliert quasi eine
arm cpu um diesen kram ausführen zu können
bringt zwar nicht aber ich brauche ein bisschen brauche ein bisschen rechenleistung guck hier
zu leisten genau
wir können übrigens das offizielle dotnet image verwenden dafür das wir brauchen hier
gar keinen gar kein zu installieren
Not found ja ich weiß weil du es gar nicht installierst
Wir brauchen ab install karl weil das ist standardmäßig gar nicht dabei
guckt seht ihr die emulierte cpu das wow wow wow wow monkaS also worauf ich raus will ist man
kann eine armen cpu auf einem x86 emulieren und das braucht halt wahnsinnig viel cpu last
weil der halt das übersetzen muss dass es aussieht wie am cpu so und theoretisch kann
man so images bauen auf seinem desktop die x86 unterstützt und am unterstützen das problem
ist nur dort nett hat ein back und das ist das worauf ich eigentlich raus will das zeige
ich euch jetzt wir machen das hiermit ich zeige euch dass es hiermit ein back hat und
dass es auch mit dem offiziellen dort nett docker image im back hat da gibt es ein kleines
problem was mich davon abhält das so zu machen wie ich mir das hier vorstelle
guck jetzt lädt er sich das dort nett runtime runter und führt das aus es gibt
unter dort nett die möglichkeit die sachen direkt für abend zu kompilieren von x86 rechner
aus aber wir können nicht alles auf einmal machen ich zeige erstmal was ich mir gedacht
habe hat github actions keine arm 64 runner ich glaube nicht in der free version du kannst
deinen eigenen machen kannst du raspberry pi nehmen dafür github actions arm runner
du kannst deinen eigenen nehmen guck der macht es auch mit qmo ja man auch qmo die machen
alle die machen alle qmo das es geht auch ohne scheiß qmo ist relativ schnell also für
so ein einfaches bild reicht das das problem ist nur dass dort netten back hat und sich
nicht in qmo bauen lässt was an sich kein problem ist weil du weil dort netter selbst
unterstützt für abend architektur zu kompilieren ohne dass du die ganze container geschichte
machen musst es sei denn oder komme zum knackpunkt es sei denn man benutzt native interop also
sprich man muss irgendwelche sachen aufrufen von c libraries oder so dann sieht das ganze
schon wieder ein bisschen anders aus dann funktioniert das funktioniert das theoretisch auch aber
die c libraries und sachen die muss man natürlich dann auf einem echten armen container kompilieren
oder aber cross compilen und sonst wie muss man kurz schauen run mk dir slash ab man könnte
auch wirklich nehmen dort net new console schon ob das jetzt funktioniert soweit ich
will euch zeigen dass es von ks ok das muss den krempel noch installieren lip eq 70 immer
gar nicht sicher was es für eine version ist so und dann werdet ihr sehen es krascht gleich
nein nicht da lip alter wie heißt das aktuelle package bei debian was ich ok wisst ihr wisst
ihr was wir machen wir sind jetzt wir sind jetzt ganz ganz trickreich wir starten das
jetzt einfach und ich gucke da drin nach docker run oder bin bash gehen wir weg wir starten
jetzt einfach den container und ich gucke mal wie das package heißt search update lip
eco 67 meine güte hast du jetzt nachgeguckt oder weißt du das lip eco da das brauche
das ist voraussetzung für dort net es ist so ziemlich die einzige abhängigkeit die
man damit hat man hat die abhängigkeit allerdings auch nicht hardcoded sondern nur wenn man
so internationalisierungs sachen verwendet wie zum beispiel euro als währung und zeitzonen
und solche geschichten ja wenn man standard glücklich ist mit der standard englischen
schreibweise und so dann braucht man das alles nicht und jetzt sollte er new console machen
und abkacken oder oder beim bild spätestens wird er abkacken man sieht er emuliert wieder
hier in der armen cpu drunter und das ganze zieht ordentlich cpu last also den container
auf meinem haus baute in fünf sekunden und hier braucht er jetzt schon 30 weil halt emulation
nicht das schnellste ist ihr könnt euch vorstellen wenn ein desktop rechner schon probleme hat
ein raspberry pie schnell zu emulieren was es eigentlich für eine big brain geschichte
ist so was wie in den gamecube zu emulieren so jetzt install der dotnet und dann sollte
er hoffentlich beim erstellen der anwendung abkacken du wusstest wusstest du das wirklich
aus dem kopf richtig six hat leute massive high IQ dazu kann man nur sagen wo habe ich
mein big brain sound leute hat so dämlich an was hältst du von open media volt abstand
mag ich nicht wie das hat funktioniert wait a minute moment self contained wenn das funktioniert
wäre massive dann kann ich die container ordentlich bauen ja das ist das wäre richtig
gut aber wie gesagt es würde mich wundern weil dort netter ein back das funktioniert
nicht kann man weglassen self content publik gutes lasen wir mal alles weg output bild
das funktioniert das wird mich ganz stark wundern wenn das funktioniert ok ms bild ja
jetzt kackt er ab jetzt kackt er ab richtig so muss das sein und zwar das ding emuliert
zwar eine armen cpu aber irgendwie haben sie es geschafft dass dort net verbackt ist
im emulator du kannst kein dort net zeug im emulator für 32 bit arm 47 packagen und
kompilieren das geht nicht da gibt es auch ein back zu den habe ich gefunden der back
ist ihr dürft mal raten wie alt er ist bevor ich ihn aufmache ratet mal wie alt er ist
ratet mal wann dieser back reported wurde und wie viele sich dafür interessieren 2016
jahre ich glaube das kommt ganz gut hin was 2020 wie wirklich das ist ja noch gar nicht
so alt das ist ja nur zweieinhalb jahre alt jetzt na guck mal nur zwei jahre alt ist nix
so das ist kaputt seit q emo release 1 e3 konfig da hat sich doch gar nichts großartig
geändert also seit q emo release 4.2 es ist kaputt mit q emo release 4.1 und 4.11 hat
es noch funktioniert ja das ist eine komische library die merkwürdige dinger macht wisst
ihr was sein kann dass der das sogar nur zu gitlab umgezogen hat dass die comments also
dass die eigentlichen sachen noch noch älter sind guck mal das kommt noch von launchpad
das ubuntu gedöns ja und es hat sich nichts getan also der back ist immer noch drin und
man kann dort net nicht in einem armen container bilden also in einem armen emulierten auf
einer emulierten armen cpu das ist das verbuckt so was man jetzt eventuell machen könnte
ist q emo 4.1 verwenden aktuell sind wir übrigens bei q emo 7 also man könnte irgendwie eine
frag mich nicht achtjahre alte q emo version verwenden oder so das ist aber nicht sinn
und zweck der sache ja ok man könnte eine drei jahre alte q emo version verwenden und
hoffen dass es damit funktioniert kontributen kann ich das nicht mehr das kriegen das kriege
ich nicht hin aber es funktioniert nicht das ist kaputt oder man muss sich irgendwas anderes
überlegen die offizielle variante von was microsoft empfiehlt ist folgendes die empfehlen
nämlich ein multistage bild microsoft empfiehlt dass man so sachen wie bild x und sowas gar
nicht erst verwendet sondern dass man ein package macht dass man das dass man das packaged
s bild oder so oder s bild s heckel bild und dann ein zweites images nimmt v7 slash debian
oder sowas und das dann da rein kopiert also microsoft empfiehlt bau das auf x86 rechner
und dann kopier es in den arm 32 image das ist ok das geht aber schön ist es nicht vor
allem wenn man noch native libraries bilden möchte dann ist das nicht so dolle da müsste
man quasi das ja aber gut dass das funktioniert dann kann man nämlich hier sagen copy from
hat sogar auto verfolgt kann man sagen hier copy from von diesem einen container kopieren
den anderen container rein und zwar kopiere aus diesem bild jetzt mal alles von slash
ab nach slash ab zum beispiel oder von slash ab bild kopier das rüber in den container
das geht das ist die empfohlene variante von microsoft das zu machen das kann man natürlich
nicht bild x verwenden sondern man braucht zwei unterschiedliche bild files für amd
64 und und und arm weil der bild für amd 64 würde anders aussehen er würde ein anderes
image verwenden und auch diesen bildschritt hier oben nicht das ist halt doof mal gucken
ob das jetzt funktioniert mit was ich da gemacht habe so der macht jetzt nämlich folgendes
der macht hier ein container baut das programm da drinnen das funktioniert jetzt nicht ich
muss es sogar hier noch abhängig machen ich muss hier noch sagen linux linux arm sollte
er bilden so und dann nach das kopierte das fertig kompilierte hier in diesen container
rein den ich dann starten könnte beispielsweise auf dem raspberry pi das ist halt echt weiß
ich das ist irgendwie eklig das gefällt mir nicht schöner wäre es und deutlich einheitlicher
zu bauen wäre es würde das hier funktioniert einfach auf jeder plattform als mit mit bild
x ja dass der dann einen armen emulator nimmt das baut und übrigens ich mache das gleich
noch mal rückgängig ich muss euch auch noch was zeigen es ist nämlich nicht alles verbackt
es ist nur amd 32 amd v7 verbackt amd 864 bitt funktioniert aber nicht jeder hat einen
raspberry pi 4 oder raspberry pi 3 mit 64 bitt betriebssystem drauf auf machinne ich
glaube die meisten sind noch auf dem 32 bitt raspberry pi oder wie sieht es bei euch aus
werden raspberry pi hat chat wir machen mal eine umfrage wir machen mal eine umfrage
32 bitt 64 bitt umfrage
ich muss gar nicht so vor immer ein virtual box haben glaube ich gar keine armen emulationen
oder vor immer relativ sicher hat sowas sowas nicht außerdem kann man vor immer nicht in
github actions laufen lassen vor immer workstation haben die armen emulationen oder
also die meisten haben es tatsächlich auf vielen sechst mit laufen ok hätte ich nicht
gedacht aber trotzdem immerhin die hälfte sagen wir die hälfte die hälfte die hälfte
sagen wir jetzt mal ja ok das heißt die hier könnten alle das nicht ausführen wenn es
vielen sechst mit gebildet ist was genau baut er denn da bitte schön so lang
was macht er da ich meine das ist eine konsolenanwendung hallo keck weight was bildest du da drei stunden
rum man das dauert 15 sekunden normalerweise hat er sich aufgehängt guck mal 38 38 40
das ist übelst am abscheißen gerade der macht da einfach gar nix richtig boomersoft
ja der braucht einfach zehn gigabyte ram für was für was zumindest ich zeige euch
jetzt mal dass es auch funktionieren kann das war so wenn man das ganze nämlich bildet
mit arm 64 8 8 eine güde platform multiplatform bilds hier nein nein nein das stimmt so nicht
linux arm 64 ist es passt wenn man das nämlich damit macht dann auf magische art und weise
funktioniert es einfach also dieser bug trifft nur 32 bit arm v7 cpus es ist so es ist so
hängen geblieben das könnte mit abstand das einfachste sein ja das ist alles was ich
bräuchte um ein add-on zu packagen also theoretisch noch einfacher ich nehme nämlich einfach
das microsoft image weil die haben nämlich fertige fertige docker images da könnte man
nämlich jetzt zum beispiel das dann eben sdk sdk 7.0 hier nehmen wir einfach das da die
versionsnummer hinten dran und fertig zeige ich euch mal schnell dass man dass das funktioniert
wir nehmen einfach ups man muss schon das richtige richtige image kopieren so einfach das dahinten
dran dann kann ich das da wegschmeißen das da wegschmeißen das da wegschmeißen braucht
wirklich nur noch den bildstep und ihr seht ihr werdet gleich sehen mit arm 64 kein problem
funktioniert ich sollte mal meine images gleich wieder wegschmeißen ich habe nicht so viel
Platz also das ist ja falsch ist ja schon vor installiert dotnet rc-1 ist nicht stabil
ne aber es funktioniert besser mit dotnet 6 funktioniert noch überhaupt nicht das ist
alles was ich theoretisch bräuchte um die app zu bauen also ich anstatt eine neue konsolen
anwendung würde ich dann halt meine app rüber kopieren jaja mit das ist egal also egal ob
ubuntu elpein oder sonst wie was wir können auch mal hier alpine aber auch nehmen gleich
guckt man sieht ja das tut wunderbar coemu emulierten arm cpu und es kackt nicht ab es
geht einfach was halt echt kacke ist das heißt ich muss mir jetzt irgendein workaround überlegen
und zwar so dass das image beziehungsweise das dockerfile nicht also ich will nicht zwei
dockerfiles und builds machen und da bin ich gerade ein bisschen ein bisschen unschlüssig
wie man das machen könnte gescheit und wenn man das hat dann kann man das ja auch in der
github action bauen also ihr seht schon es ist trotzdem relativ langsam es ist singel
weil halt emulierte cpu ich glaube multithreading emulieren die nicht so und braucht halt ein
bisschen irgendwann fällt ein fertiges bild raus und da liegt dann die anwendung rum so
was ich mir sonst noch überlegt habe was man machen könnte ist wie gesagt bild x funktioniert
nicht man könnte docker in docker machen oder aber tatsächlich ein komplettes komplettes
coemu starten mit eigenem image gucken ob es da dann drin funktioniert aber ich glaube
das kann man sich sparen das wird wahrscheinlich auch nicht funktionieren wenn es irgendein
bug in der coemu emulation ist tja man könnte eine uralt coemu variante nehmen und hoffen
dass es damit funktioniert was aber auch doof ist weil wenn es dann irgendwelche anderen
bugs gibt ist halt müll also ich gehe davon aus es wird darauf rauslaufen dass man die
doch net anwendung auf also das ist aber alles gerade sehr sehr langsam also so extrem langsam
sollte es nicht sein meine hängt hier zwar ist doch ist das irgendwie kaputt das frisst
einfach das frisst einfach irgendwie 60 irgendwie irgendwie 6 gigabyte ram oder so
bisschen broken oder bis bis bisschen bisschen broken und woran stört er sich jetzt ich
meine viel kann er da nicht kaputt gehen mit der alten coemo version da müssen wir
erst mal gucken wo man eine alte coemo version überhaupt herkriegt dieses wie ist dieses
image was ich da installiert habe bin ja tons ist bütz bütz gebück wenn man den ausspricht
mal gucken ob der überhaupt eine alte coemo version hat ist das new console interactive
null console app was successfully created restoring was macht der denn da so lang was
ist das was ist das ist so kaputt es ist mir sogar eben schon auf maus abgekackt also
normalerweise nur mal so normalerweise sagste dort net new console und dann ist fertig das
was also das sollte das sollte auch selbst bei emulierter cpu nicht so lange dauern
wie es hier dauert also da ist auch da ist noch was anderes im arsch gachi bass so was
ist die älteste coemo version die dieser typ hier hat kurma tags coemo das kein kvm
ne ne das ist alles in software coemo v ne doch v6 hat er v5 hat er v4 hat er nicht scheiße
wir brauchen 4.1 das fällt schon mal flach es ist auf jeden fall nicht normal dass er
so viel ram frisst und wisst ihr was mir allgemein bisschen bisschen bedenken bedenken macht
ist dass wenn ich wir machen einfach nur docker bild ja ob das wenigstens funktioniert weil
normales docker bild müsste quasi instant durchlaufen auf x86 hardware ich glaube der
hat halt irgendwelche anderen schmerzen bei mir mein docker ist kaputt der hängt immer
selbst selbst auf x86 das dauert fünf sekunden normalerweise der ist broken gerade was sagst
du zu overwatch 2 ich habe es noch nicht gespielt warte mein docker zeug ist kaputt das macht
einfach gar nichts mehr selbst normales bild geht nicht mehr ich muss mal ich muss mal
kurz neu starten ich glaube ich glaube und prunen müssen wir ja und war das coemo zeug
hier installieren prune docker was ist denn system prunen aha das will remove all stop
containers all networks not used by at least one container all dangling images yes bam
docker hat er das auch gemacht post jam muss man auch minus a machen so docker warum hat
er das bei images warum hat das system nicht gemacht was minus minus all ne force will
ich nicht gibt es system minus minus all ok also er hat zumindest ein bisschen was wieder
freigeben ich leute ich reboote mal ich weiß nicht was der für schmerzen hat gerade wir
rebooten mal rebooten hilft immer dankeschön leute für die ganzen follows und subs massive
subscriptions hier wieder muss man kurz sicherstellen dass die musik wieder von vorne los geht ja
mal macht so jetzt schauen wir mal wenn es wieder wenn es wieder hoch kommt der hinten
ist übrigens nicht mein hintergrund das ist bing image of the day wir gehen in den besten
ordner überhaupt moment temp keck wie gibt ach du scheiße meine verzeichnisse wieder
man das findet es finde ich doch wieder alles nicht massive namen ja so docker bild punkt
auf geht's also das sollte instant durchlaufen wenn nicht hat mein docker irgendeinen schlag
weg also ich habe euch gezeigt wie schnell das lokal ist das dauert fünf sekunden hier
normalerweise
mein docker ist kaputt
der ist broken der ist einfach nur langsam macht gar nichts und und hängt das ist nicht
weil rc1 6.0 das ist nicht das ist nicht weil rc1 das ist irgendwas anderes zeit für
die neue vm kann sein auf
der hängt und hat unendlich viel ram verbrauch aber ich meine hat ja schon mal funktioniert
aber kann man diesen mist wieder deinstallieren
das ist eh nur im container installiert gewesen also irgendwie ist mein docker jetzt voll
im arsch macht gar nichts mehr ist natürlich auch geil jetzt kann man kann ich bild ok
das ist gar nicht das ist gar nicht drinne ja das ist auch nicht so dass der versucht
jetzt amd 64 auf amd 64 zu emulieren oder so es ist einfach procken installiert deinstalliert
es einfach bild ex docker bild punkt ok leute ich habe ernsthaft keinen plan warum das ding
kaputt ist warum das gar nicht mal funktioniert macht das macht das irgendwas noch
liegt vielleicht am cd ne warum ich kann auch nur dass da reinschreiben es wird trotzdem
nicht funktionieren also irgendwie ich habe keine ahnung warum irgendwie haben jetzt mein
docker zeug kaputt gemacht also mein dotnet im docker haben wir irgendwie irgendwie zerstört
hat das internet zugriff ja bestimmt aber brauchst brauchst nicht wirklich wir machen
jetzt mal trick 17 wir starten jetzt mal ein ubuntu und gucken ob wenn ich interaktiv starte
dass da funktioniert ab update weil nicht upgrade install install karl lip iq 70 ist
es bei denen glaube jawoll prinzipiell läuft ja noch aber dort net ist gerade einfach einfach
procken ja macht gar nichts mehr und warum man weiß es nicht genau und ich habe die
vm schon rebooted das läuft ja heute wieder wie am schlürchen mk dir ab dotnet dotnet new console das
funktioniert moment leute moment warum funktioniert das und das offizielle image verreckt das ist das
ist komisch moment vom ubuntu da machen wir das doch jetzt mal so 22 ne slash ne doppelpunkt 22
0 22 10 genau dann machen wir da jetzt nicht den kram jetzt noch mal von hunter drauf also run
ab update und und ab install minus y karl ist das ist das image von denen irgendwie kaputt
gerade ist da irgendwas drinne was nicht drin sein sollte oder warum ist das warum ist das so
so procken ist 22 punkt 10 schon raus aber kann nicht mehr lange dauern ob das kommt
endlich bekommen 22 ist auch egal 22 04 auch ok so und jetzt machen wir so so das müsste jetzt
müsste doch jetzt eigentlich funktionieren dass er dann so karl run installen dort net und dann
machen wir jetzt wieder das übliche run mk dir slash ab cd nach ab console new hier das da dotnet console new so bild gib ihm gib ihm bin ich mal gespannt
was ja so 70 leb ego 70 was schauen ob es jetzt geht dann ist vielleicht das offizielle image
irgendwie marsch was aber nix daran ändert dass es verbackt ist dass es nicht funktioniert warum
nicht direkt die runtime warst du vor 30 sekunden da das funktioniert na geil dann ist das offizielle
image kaputt wir hatten die runtime gerade dies das das geht nicht das offizielle image
geht nicht selbstgemachtes funktioniert aus irgendwelchen gründen alles klar easy das muss
ich jetzt aber nicht verstehen das muss ich echt nicht verstehen jetzt mein meinetwegen
ist soll mir auch recht recht sein dann verifizieren wir nochmal das ist dass das wirklich kaputt
ist das bild ja dort net ist gut was hat jetzt verschmerzten ok was ist ich also
haben wir irgendwo verschrieben leute item group wat warning was was willst du von mir
moment das funktioniert oder das kack gar nicht ab das funktioniert jetzt hängt es
wieder was zum also heute ist es irgendwie voll im arsch oder jetzt hängt jetzt hängt
es einfach wieder komplett also irgendwas ist da ist da ist da hinüber lebt ja nicht
70 ist weil es aktuell obuntu ist das debian hat hat 67 gebraucht was ist es aber ist haben
die irgendwas gepusht was was brauchen ist oder glaube ich net das wird das wird an mir
liegen aber jetzt hängt wieder versteht irgendjemand was das für was was meine container für
schmerzen haben gerade mit diesem microsoft krempe
also ich verstehe es gar nicht es leuchtet überhaupt nicht ein warum das manchmal hängt
und manchmal nicht hängt liegt an microsoft im zweifelsfall muss es an microsoft liegen
aber es kann nicht an microsoft liegen leute weil 6.0 funktioniert auch nicht und 6.0 ist
stabil das muss gehen ich habe dort net schon öfters im container verwenden das geht eigentlich
guck mal da was das jedes andere jetzt auch also da kann man doch gar nicht so viel verkehrt
machen könntest du den echo step setzen ja wobei er hat er gerade neu installiert weil
ich weil ich umgestellt habe auf 6 also das ist irgendwie das das blick ich jetzt nicht
was der für schmerzen hat der lädt es runter der legt die konsolen anwenden der kann aber
kein publish machen noch mal prunen habe ich doch erst ich habe sogar restarted
auch konsolen anwenden aber jetzt hat es funktioniert ne ach runtime identifier muss ich machen
ja ok das ist klar weil es dort net 6 ist da muss ich sagen minus r linux in linux x64
ist es linux x64 linux 64 what the fuck also irgendwas ist mit meinem docker zeug kaputt
da hängt da hängt das das hängt zu 90 prozent und ich habe keine ahnung warum ich mache
wirklich noch mal alle alle images weg und ich restarted docker klein noch mal irgendwas
ist da richtig im arsch wir müssen in die qt vm die qt vm ist ubuntu 1804 oder sowas
aber nee guck du mal das das hängt einfach komplett also jetzt blick ich nicht mal was
der verschmerz was die für schmerzen haben also das habe ich schon so oft gemacht entweder
mit dem offiziellen image oder selbst runter das geht eigentlich immer warum sollte das
nicht funktionieren richtig hängen geblieben ja auch dass der hier rummeckert von irgendwelchen
warnings was man gerade aus dem das ist auch ganz merkwürdig ich war ein wecker über
irgendwelche warnings ich lege das mit dem offiziellen template an auf auf shithub bauen
ja das geht wahrscheinlich aber warum ist mein lokal ist so wie restart noch mal kurz docker
lokal sollte eigentlich nix sein es ist volume so und jetzt noch mal restarten
hätte er nicht
und ich habe keinen plan warum das hängt da ist irgendwas grundsätzlich gerade total
im arsch an meiner docker ins oder von was auch immer es scheint ja nur dort netzzeug
zu sein was hängt beim bild publish ja x64 ich habe es auch richtig ich habe es auch
richtig geschrieben ja jetzt weiß ich wirklich nicht weiter der trotzdem noch was aus dem
cash benutzt aber das wird es nicht sein ich meine ich kann sogar mal Ubuntu 20 04 nehmen
irgendwas was ich noch gar nicht installiert hatte es muss funktionieren ich habe morgen
noch was gebaut sogar mit 7 7 funktioniert auch das ist irgendwas was an mir das liegt
tatsächlich ist man ist schnell bei Microsoft aber das liegt nicht an Microsoft ich meine
das der einzige unterschied ist ich habe vorhin ein komplettes system update gemacht ich meine
vielleicht wirklich irgendwas drin was kaputt gemacht hat bill weiß ja nicht kann man irgendwie
sein docker komplett resetten oder so ich meine man kann sein dings sein die hier löschen
aber das bringt ja nix das kann man doch verzeihen ist löschen aber das jetzt nicht wirklich
wirklich bringen das habe ich schon das bringt anscheinend nix ok mal was noch mal bild haben
wir alles können wir rückgängig machen und das offizielle image dem no bild cash ja gut
jetzt haben wir alles gelöscht jetzt kann er nichts mehr cashen der scheiß hängt einfach
ok das kann also das kann kurz dauern aber wie gesagt in self contain bild von der konsolen
anwendung dauert normalerweise dauert normalerweise 5 sekunden oder so so fertig so lang dauert
das normalerweise so so schnell müsste das im container auch gehen was mich ein stark
verwirrt ist am anfang lief das ja schon mal durch das ist der was wir jetzt machen man
das trick 17 das ist das neue was wir installiert haben ne das ist ganz alte ups ne ach quatsch
nicht reset power off arch by the way wir probieren mal eine andere file maus das andere fällt
mir gerade nicht ein warum es nicht funktionieren sollte ist überhaupt schon soweit eingerichtet
dass es funktionieren kann ok da hinten fest schon mal da excellent schon mal halbe miete
firefox auch alles da wunderbar wunderbar sogar schon installiert nahe natürlich noch
nicht meine farben gehen auch nicht richtig oder terminal farben sind auch brocken alles
klar wird probieren was probieren was mal hier drin code ist auch nicht installiert
ist nichts installiert ich muss das man update machen fällt mir gerade ein das ist ja ne
ne ne ne warte mal warte mal pack man pack man minus things irgendwie so so ne so alter
jetzt ist f so das geht ja relativ schnell wir haben ja multiple downloads an aber warum
ist mein container so also warum ist mein docker so im arsch das dort net da drin immer
gibt sagen die muss ich nicht verstehen das ganz schön langsam was ist mit dem mir los
guckt euch das mal an ne wobei ist er nicht er hat total immerhin noch ein paar ist bloß
das große zeug am anfang guck mal das relativ relativ schnell und der ganze shit weil so
schnell ist er nicht hier schaut mal das ein paar ne da ist ziemlich langsam sogar mir
aus eine güde da ist der ist nicht schnell
also bunte image hat vieles net was standard ist und weiter ja es liegt bestimmt am battlefield
muss ich den cupanates cluster erst deployen dass es wieder geht aber aber nicht nicht
lokal also mindestens mal bei drei verschiedenen cloud provider dann ist es da sind die container
vielleicht zufriedengestellt dann geht dann geht mein docker auch wieder aber das hatte
ich auch noch nicht dass es so kaputt ist das muss das kann ja im endeffekt nur was
damit zu ja ja importieren das kann im endeffekt nur was damit zu tun haben dass ich irgendwelche
q emo sachen installiert habe was haben eigentlich für eine kernel version drauf also ich habe
ja kein man da rum aber art offizielles arch beide jetzt du du du du du du du du du du
du du du du so und jetzt schauen wir gleich ob es funktioniert auf ja gibt uns viel muss
mal schief gucken haben wir so also installiert jetzt aber
wischl studio code brauchen wir auch noch ähm wie heißt denn der krämpel ja ob ob elektron 9
geh weg so mk dir tem das wenigstens gleich dumme verzeichnisse bei beidem machen dass
ich miss merken kann fast doch auf einmal muss ich noch neu starten wegen köln update so ich
habe noch gar keine wischl studio code kommt ist das ist das comic sans was das für eine
standardschrift sieht aber abartig schlecht aus und ne settings stellt man das überhaupt ein
fond hack hack ist der beste font beste hack 20 oder sara schon näher 28 wie groß 24 ja
es ist aber nicht der font ist auch nicht hackers hack
habe ich das nicht installiert
kein hack font wie ging das font config font cache font cache oder so
fc font cache oder list hack ist doch drauf da hack font oder muss ich hack regular nennen
das was er kennt habe ich eigentlich für ein dreckiges terminal chat was habt ihr mir da für
terminal i was das kann man nicht mal rechts klingen was habe ich da installiert was habt
ihr mir da empfohlen
ja aber auch nicht besser aus ich weiß nicht mal wie ich meine schrift hat
meine schrift hat funktioniert richtig ekliges terminal ok reboot
moment es ist pc speaker ist auch noch alles wird ja immer schlimmer wie soll man diese
form für irgendwas verwenden
was mit was für unfertigen sachen müssen wir uns in hier rumschlagen ist das way das ist i3
weil weyland und sway nicht in vm war funktioniert gescheit so viel zu
weyland wird x ersetzt also ok das stimmt nicht ganz was ich gesagt habe weyland funktioniert
in vmw wenn man nichts möchte also wenn es einem nichts ausmacht dass ein screen nicht
refreshed also wenn ihr mit null fps leben könnt wie sich euer desktop aufbaut dann geht
weyland auch und ich meine wirklich null fps der screen refreshed nicht
es ist nicht ein frame es sind wirklich null frames der bildschirm baut sich nicht auf
es gibt ein workaround mit environment variablen aber dann stellt man fest dass copy paste
nicht funktioniert es ist komplett für arsch unbenutzbar docker bild
oje system ctl restart docker ach ich bin ich in der docker group sag das doch gleich
muss in die docker group user mod chat wer hat es im kopf wer ist so six headache docker
max so war das richtig ja tatsächlich muss man muss man irgendwie x neu starten dass
das funktioniert kommen die docker group das läuft überhaupt net enable docker permission
denied so aber als root sollte es gehen und ich bin jetzt in der in der group drinne wahrscheinlich
wahrscheinlich muss ich mich noch mal ausfragen es sei es genau so können wir jetzt anfangen
please ich bin ja docker group wie kann ich wie kann ich permission denied haben ok wisst
ihr was ist mir egal
war war run docker ach arminus g was ist nur minus g passt doch was ist der unterschied
zu minus g und arminus g so du minus logins skript zu starten ich bin doch in der docker
group ist append na ja mein große unterschied sollte es eigentlich machen oder nur g ist
taubgruppe habe ich meinen user jetzt irgendwie kaputt gemacht oder ich frage ist jetzt viel
eher ist viel eher warum geht der scheiß net es gehört der dockergruppe und ich bin
in der dockergruppe ich habe schon gelockt ich kann rebooten war keck aber das willst
nicht bringen ich habe schon gelockt aller pc speaker ich habe schon gelockt man das
irgendwie machen wir ja wir gucken gerade mit genau du hast recht wir gucken ob das funktioniert
easy easy einfach einfach rebooten einfach rebooten kein ding kein thema easy so mal
gucken ob unser dotnet bild jetzt funktioniert docker bild punkt hart hopp schauen wir mal
er flutscht schon deutlich schneller
ja gib ihm gib ihm das kann doch nicht sein dass das hängt
es ist aber ist die docker version verpackt oder was ich habe hunderte container gebaut
mit dort net drinnen und die haben nie die hängen nicht warum warum hängt das das ist
eine neue v was jetzt das ist eine neue vm das ding frisst endloschleife speicher und
alles ok das verstehe das ist irgendwie vielleicht ist irgendwas mit der dockerversion downgrade
aber das so da war es downgrade ich glaube es war downgrade downgrade docker ja ja so
was nennt man da jetzt die da vor die da
hängt wieder also jetzt blicke ich dann mal durch das ist mir jetzt zu hoch docker bild
ist einfach ist pro geht nicht mehr also dort net wohlgemerkt nur dort net docker bild geht
nicht mehr ist kaputt und frisst meinen kompletten ram restore das das leht irgendwelche das
das leht irgendwelche abhängigkeiten oder so aber das egal es hängt nicht nur beim
restore wobei warte mal hat microsoft bei nuke hat probleme was in zeite 13 steht dort
net publish die ms images die gehen auch nicht daraufhin habe ich erstmal ein eigenes gemacht
also ich meine wir können ausschließen wir können ausschließen dass es irgendwie an
microsoft liegt weil wenn ich es lokal bei mir installier geht alles das ist die neue
vm es geht nirgendswo und ich habe keine ahnung warum guck ich kann es mal lokal machen
jetzt
ist aber aber hyper hyper advanced easy geht einfach leute das verzeichnis ist doch vollkommen
egal der darf nicht hängen der muss einfach abkacken oder durchlaufen in ein paar sekunden
oder macht nichts davon er hängt was glaube ich unsinnig ist ich weiß nicht warum der
hängt also ich habe wirklich keine keine keine wirklich absolut keine sinnvolle erklärung
dafür gerade zumal er manchmal ja wohl auch durchläuft also bei microsoft ist alles gut
sonst wird das nicht funktionieren wir machen noch mal was anderes gehen wir mit also da
vor ihm liegt schon mal net darf sich mal wieder verabschieden wir machen was anderes also
wir starten den krempel noch mal interaktiv das hat das letzte mal funktioniert das ist
doch überhaupt nicht das eigentlich wollte ich was ganz anderes machen aber dazu brauche
wir funktionieren aus docker über irgendwas zum container bauen und ja geht ab action
wird garantiert funktionieren weil bei mir lokal funktioniert auch im container funktioniert
es nicht der gibt doch keinen sinn rewrite in rust genau so an docker selbst liegt auch
nicht es liegt an docker bild wenn ich in bild mache klappt es nicht wenn ich es interaktiv
ausführe klappt es wo ist denn da jetzt der sinn was soll was soll denn das für einen
fehler bitteschön sein in zwei vms unabhängig voneinander geht es nicht aber interaktiv
gehts das leuchtet mir nicht ein wozu denn wirkt ihr mann leute wenn ihr backseat macht
bewegt mal ein bisschen gedanken auch diese fehler sind sehr merkwürdig ergibt überhaupt
ist doch irgendwie habe ich da irgendwie den sinn irgendwo den schreibfehler ok wisst
ihr was wir machen das wisst ihr was wir machen mann komplett neues docker fall das
legt ein neues dotnet projekt an so wir nehmen das wir nehmen das das microsoft image wieder
wir legen komplett neues docker fall an vielleicht sind da irgendwelche sonderzeichen drin oder
so keine ahnung mittlerweile muss man ja muss man ja echt wirklich an alles an alles denken
mann alpin bild auch gut wunderbar ok dotnet new console run soll mal gucken ob das wenigstens
funktioniert docker bild wir machen ok wir machen wir machen zumindest slash blub benutzte
jetzt wirklich anders so dass zumindest bis zu dem schritt sollte es ja funktionieren
bei public hat er ja auch schmerzen gehabt das hängt schon zu lange
das ist äußerst sus leute dass es interaktiv funktioniert aber hier drinnen nett und dass
er da einfach komplett hängt was damit na ja minus das kommt aufs gleiche raus minus
o ist einfach nur wie das heißt beziehungsweise glaubt welches verzeichnis das ist es darf
auf jeden fall nicht in einer endlosschleife hängen was könnte das denn sein also ich
hab wirklich gar keine ahnung was macht minus n keine ahnung wahrscheinlich wie die wahrscheinlich
wie das der name space heißt oder so viel minimalistischer geht es doch nicht mehr das
muss irgendwie das muss irgendwas am rechner sein jetzt hier gerade wirklich kein plan
das mit wirkt ihr läuft das ist von 2021 das kann ich sein dass es da dran liegt ich
meine wir können wirkt ihr angeben aber das wie gesagt er hängt ja er hat ja keine fehler
er hängt was im endeffekt heißt dass es kein irgendwie falsch konfiguriert sondern
er versucht was zu machen aber es geht nicht was schreibt der typ hier im issue zeigt
mal her ist auch nur ansatzweise mal gucken wie gut gebackseated wird jetzt docker bild
stack und dort net restore also ich habe das auf die an und weise wie ich das hier schon
gemacht hat 100 mal gemacht das funktioniert das sind zwei zeilen also sie kriege ich schon
noch hin
nochmal kurz testen ob das jetzt ob es funktioniert und am anfang des streams hat es auch noch
funktioniert dass ja das geile anfang des streams hat es noch geklappt leute genau so
übrigens es hat ja auf einmal aufgehört zu funktionieren setzten wir mal wirkt ihr
das kann aber nicht die lösung sein
es hat am anfang des streams funktioniert ich kann es euch wenn sie das geile ist ich
habe es ja sogar im wort so ich habe ich habe später erst angefangen hier so so irgendwo
da ok guckt da haben wir noch was vergessen zu installieren
wort seating
ich gebe da nie wirkt ihr an ich habe den kram schon öfters ich habe das erst heute
morgen gemacht ohne wirkt ihr
anderes grund image ich weiß es nicht was es war das war das war auch das war ein debian
bullseye heute morgen
normalerweise funktioniert das auch
guckt da hat es funktioniert
konsole restoring das hat funktioniert das das ging dann weiter irgendwann so nach fünf
minuten oder so war es dann fertig aber ja guck guck das lief das ging vor der stunde ging
das image noch das dockerfile genau das gleiche das ging vor der stunde noch ich habe es
auf wort ich habe es auf wort wo habe ich das wort auf gehabt ja ich habe es ich habe
es auf wort dass es ging
da gibt es nicht viel zu scan ich verstehe ich habe das guck mal selbst selbst mein image
selbst mein image für mein home assistant addon hat das so gemacht
hier guckt mal selbst mein image für home assistant hat es exakt so gemacht mit dem
install und dann in dem im run file das ausgeführt sehr sehr sehr weird weird champig alles und
wirkt die app es gibt noch nicht mal eine app
äh wat achso jaja weird champ wat achso ah äh ähm run apt update install curl wie ist
der krempel da jetzt irgendjemand wusste es doch noch oder äh achten achten neunzig
achten sieben siebenundsechzig siebzig ne ne bei bullseye war es nicht ich kann noch
im stem gucken hier siebenundsechzig siebenundsechzig alles klar kann weg bei sieben ich habe den
beweis auf wie es hat funktioniert äh gut das ist jetzt die arm geschichte und mein
image hat ja auch funktioniert auf exakt die die was verstehe ich nicht es hängt wieder
das gleiche was vor einer stunde noch funktioniert hat ist jetzt kaputt geil oder wahnsinn
mal ganz davon abgesehen viel zu durchsuchen gibt es ja bei dem image noch nicht mal das
ist das ist was an guck mal der kram der frisst einfach unendlich viel ram das ist irgendeine
endloschleife mit memory leak wo das ding drinne hängt was merkwürdig ist tatsächlich dass
ich das durch ein werk dir und selbst wenn es das nicht gibt anscheinend fixen lässt
oder am ist ich jetzt nach dem install machen sollen naja und noch was anderes wenn man
das offizielle image verwendet geht das mit wirkt ihr scheint anscheinend so wirklich
zu funktionieren aber es ging vorher doch auch ich jetzt also ich ich verstehe es wirklich
ich hab es ich setze nie wirkt das wirkt ihr dafür das klappt normalerweise immer es hat
im stream vorher funktioniert
das auch immer ist doch kabel also das ist alles sehr merkwürdig
das ist alles sehr merkwürdig
keine ahnung also
ne ich mach jetzt nix mit github actions das verstehe ich absolut nicht
wenn ich es ja nicht die letzte woche fast täglich benutzt hätte ohne wirkt ihr ich
habe die letzten zwei wochen an diesem addon hier rum gebastelt und das dockerfile hatte
kein wirkt ihr und hat funktioniert
gut das ist ein alpin aber im stream hat sie auch funktioniert
es hängt ja aber was für ein bug ich meine in was ich habe doch auch nichts anderes großartig
weißte was so blablabla bild from wir brauchen ihn alpin können wir einfach mal alpin so das
brauchen wir nicht das brauchen wir auch nicht das brauchen wir auch nicht so so einem alpin
hat
Ach da fehlt, da fehlt jetzt die, na geil Weiß was ich, was die da für ein Base
Image für nehme, na geht. Ich hätte doch schon in das Problem reinlaufen müssen,
dass ich das nicht läuft. Was, was ist das? Guckt mal, das ist das gleiche Image wie
mein Erron verwendet hat und das geht. Also das verstehe ich. Also jetzt ist so die Zeit
für Verschwörungstheorien. So gibt es nicht so eine Verschwörungstheorie, dass die Welt
sich permanent ändert und keiner, ach nee Moment, die Welt ändert sich permanent, also
auch geografisch und so und von ihren Eigenschaften, aber alle Aufzeichnungen darüber ändern sich
mit und das einzige was übrig bleibt ist die Erinnerung der Leute an das wie es vorher
war und niemand anderes kann sich dran erinnern. So ist es. Das würde jetzt echt dazu passen.
So.
Wait a minute, wenn man Minus O angibt, dann geht das auch?
Ja gut, das kann sein, dass ich normal Minus O...
Das ist doch irgendein komischer Bug, oder?
Da haben wir kein Work-Deal mehr angegeben.
Was?
Wenn ich Minus O mache, ist was?
Ist da heiß in die Solution Minus?
Was macht Minus O?
Ich dachte, das ist das Outpot-Verzeichnis.
Da sind wir doch.
Ah, richtig, so.
Hey, da ist der Tool!
Wait a minute.
Habe ich das überhaupt so gemacht?
Wartet mal, das kann sein.
Ich glaub...
Ich glaub, das ist es.
Wartet mal, ich glaube...
Ich hab das normalerweise so gemacht.
Aber dann muss man doch irgendwie anders.
Ich glaub, das ist es.
Wobei, aber dann sollte es doch nicht hängen.
Nee, das ist das Problem, warum das Publish nicht geht.
Aber jetzt mal ernsthaft.
Ja doch, das kann sein.
Ich glaube, ich hab das tatsächlich nie exakt so gemacht.
Weil normalerweise kopierst du ja was rein, was schon da ist.
Und machst da drin keine neue Anwendung.
So.
Und wenn das CD nicht funktioniert,
dann legt der das hier in Slash an.
So.
Und das führt dazu, dass er hängt?
Ja.
Genau.
Wenn du...
Ach so.
Deswegen fix das, das wirkt dir auch.
Ja, okay, das ergibt Sinn.
Weil normalerweise kopier ich den Kram ja da rein.
Und leg da nichts an.
Das hab ich jetzt...
Ich mein, wer macht so was?
Das ist halt unsinnig.
Das war jetzt nur zum Testen.
Das hab ich normalerweise nicht im Dockerfall drinstehen.
Okay, das hängt an der Stelle.
Aber ich hab's im Watt, wo es funktioniert hat vorhin.
Das ist ja noch besser.
Es hat ja vorhin schon funktioniert.
Das versteh ich nicht.
Aber okay, jetzt leuchtet es mir zumindest einfach, warum das hängt.
So, wenn ich in Output angebe, hier irgendwie Slash App,
was man glaube ich an der Stelle gar nicht mehr braucht.
Dann funs das, genau.
So.
Und jetzt funktioniert das nämlich auch mit dem offiziellen Image.
Wahrscheinlich wieder.
Aber das dann einfach in irgendeine...
Warum hängt denn der überhaupt?
Und sagt nicht irgendwie Fehler beim Stellen oder sowas?
Warum hängt das Ding einfach und frisst und endlich viel Speicher?
So hundertprozentig verstanden hab ich es aber immer noch nicht.
Gut, das sieht jetzt natürlich eher aus wie das, was ich sonst drinstehen hab.
Unter anderem hier auch bei diesem Addon.
Warum ich es hier aber einmal hatte, wo es funktioniert hat, verstehe ich nicht.
Okay, was auch immer.
So eigentlich war ja das Ziel, wir wollten einen Armcontainer bauen.
Und das da drin ausführen.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt SDK.
Hier, From.
Da können wir uns nämlich den ganzen Crampel sparen.
SDK.
Machen wir wieder ein Alpine Container, da ist er immer schön klein.
Da können wir uns diesen ganzen Crampel sparen.
So.
.net.
Das sieht besser aus, ja.
Okay, es funzt, es funzt, es funzt, es funzt, okay, okay.
Okay, so.
Mein Bild X wird immer noch nicht funktionieren, weil nach wie vor.
.net verbackt es auf ARMv7.
So, auf ARM64 wird es funktionieren.
Ach nee, Moment, wir haben den Crampel immer noch nicht installiert für Armcontainer zu bilden.
Ja, machen wir gleich, machen wir gleich.
Da, der ist mal runter.
Ja, voll das, wie heißt das?
FMT Install All.
Alles klar, Obvious.
Tony, welcher Tony ist es?
Tony Stigge.
So, ARM64 sollte tun.
Ah.
Genau, hier.
QEMU, bla bla bla.
So einfach könnte der Build sein übrigens, wenn.net nicht verbackt wäre unter ARMv7.
Mein, es ist jetzt langsam, aber das ist okay.
Guck hier.
Funzt.
Jetzt haben wir ein ARM64-Spitbild.
Und jetzt, oh, oh, da haben wir nicht.
MonkaS.
Ja, okay, also auch unter ARM64 ist es verbackt.
Nice.
Sehr schön.
Perfekt.
Die Katze, das ist meine.
Linux slash ARMv7.
Also, sowohl der Build unter ARM64-Spit, ARMv8, als auch der Build unter ARM32v7 ist verbackt.
Das ist natürlich ganz besonders toll.
Also wohlgemerkt im Emulator, ja.
Direkt auf der Hardware funktioniert das.
Wenn ihr jetzt auf dem Raspberry Pi seid und das ausführt, ist gar kein Ding.
Das funktioniert.
Aber im Emulator ist broken AF.
Guck hier.
Normale QEMO mag nicht.
Genau.
Also es war unter ARM64-Spit verbackt.
Dementsprechend unser 2-3-Spit auch verbackt.
Braucht aber wahrscheinlich einfach bloß länger für, guck mal, 60-60.
Normalerweise ist es 5 Sekunden, hier dauert es 75.
Ach ja, und was ich festgestellt habe, ist, im Emulator crasht er manchmal.
Also nicht crashen, da hängt er manchmal wirklich unendlich lang mit 100% CPU-Lass.
Das habe ich schon mal gesehen.
Deswegen im Emulator, also unter QEMO-Builden ist es halt crap mit.NET.
Ich weiß nicht warum, so ziemlich alles andere bildet, aber.NET hat kein Bock.
Zu wirklich brauchen tut man es ja auch nicht.
Es wäre halt cool, wenn man ein Docker-File hat für alle Plattformen.
Ansonsten bräuchte man halt für jede eins, weil es nicht ordentlich funktioniert.
Chat, soll ich mal abbrechen?
Ich habe das blöde Gefühl, das tut nicht mehr.
Wie kriegen wir da jetzt ein altes QEMO drauf?
Angeblich geht das ja mit...
Wie heißt der Kram? Bin?
Okay, das da will ich haben mit QEMO 4.
4.1.
Das gibt es aber nicht mit QEMO 4.1.
Ey, das ist broken, das ist kaputt.
Das hängt.
Können wir was anderes ausprobieren?
Das habe ich auch schon mir vorhin rausgesucht.
Es gibt noch ein anderes Projekt, das heißt Multiarch QEMO.
Da kann man auch irgendwie Arm-CPU auf AMD 64 emulieren.
Und dann gucken wir mal.
Vielleicht hat das ja QEMO 4.
Tags.
Was haben wir denn hier? Minus 4?
Nee, nee, nee, wir brauchen 4.1.
Hey, QEMO 4.1 am Start.
Das wollen wir haben.
Also was? Multiarch QEMO, wie verwendet man den Krempel überhaupt?
Das tut nicht hier.
Wie verwendet man das überhaupt?
Aha.
Sollen wir abbrechen kurz?
Ich hoffe, der Kram kommt sich jetzt nicht in die Quere.
Dieses eine...
Binary FMT und...
Nee, anscheinend nicht.
Und was kann man jetzt machen?
Arm 64 und bunte. Okay, dann funktioniert es.
So, jetzt haben wir das neueste.
Das wird jetzt natürlich dann hier jetzt auch nicht funktionieren.
Wenn KVM verwendet wird...
KVM ist eigentlich...
Nur dafür da... Also es ist für VMs auf der gleichen Architektur da.
Also du kannst KVM, du kannst eine VM erstellen für...
Du kannst eine x86 VM mit einer x86 CPU erstellen und sowas.
Aber du kannst mit KVM glaube ich keine...
Keine Arm CPU.
Genau, das geht nämlich.
Genau, das hat mit KVM nichts zu tun.
Das ist dann das ist das Standard QEMO Zeug.
Okay, das scheint unendlich lang zu hängen an der Stelle wieder.
Nur kurz checken, dass das Docker Build an sich immer noch funktioniert.
Ja, okay.
Plattform...
AMD 64.
Das sollte jetzt auch durchlaufen.
Ja, easy.
Funktioniert noch alles, gut.
So ARMv7.
So, okay, dann machen wir mal das gleiche jetzt mit...
Welcher Version?
Haben wir 4 Punkt?
Nee, oh Mist, jetzt hab ich's.
Hab ich den Docker noch irgendwo auf?
Multi.
Ja, so, jetzt schauen wir mal.
Mal gucken, ob das funktioniert mit 4.1.
4.1.1, na alles klar.
Einfach so hier als Tag hinten dran.
Machen wir mal run.net restore.
Das reicht ja wahrscheinlich schon.
.net.
Komm, wisst ihr was?
Wisst ihr was?
Wir machen einfach.net run.
Dann sehen wir wenigstens, dass da schön Hello World hinten dran steht.
CD slash App.
Und und.net run.
Da soll jetzt Hello World stehen, wenn es funktioniert.
Hey!
Okay, nochmal mit dem normalen.
Ohne irgendwelche spezielle QEMO-Versionen.
Bild X.
X.
Mal gucken.
Oder hing das schon beim Console, beim Create?
Nee, wir hängen jetzt an anderer Stelle.
Wir hängen ja, wir hängen an anderer Stelle.
Allein schon das Console anlegen dauert viel zu lang, trotz Emulation.
Okay, ich mache jetzt die andere QEMO-Version und hoffe, dass es funktioniert.
Was haben die hier nochmal an diesem Bugreport gesagt?
Arm-V7-KVM.
Ja, das ist wenn du es auf dem Raspberry Pi laufen lässt.
Ja, das ist klar.
Wenn du es in einer KVM-VM, also quasi eine Arm-VM auf einer Arm-Hardware laufen lässt,
dann funktioniert es.
Das ist klar.
Habt ihr schon das?
Nee, habe ich nicht.
Guck mal, habe ich irgendwelche Questions übersehen?
Wenn ich Leute, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt oder irgendwelche anderen Themen habt,
haust einfach mal in den Chat.
Ich habe jetzt noch eine halbe Stunde, also bin ich vielleicht noch da.
Ich habe jetzt auch langsam echt die Nase voll von Containerkrempel.
Okay, das funktioniert auf jeden Fall nicht.
So, wir machen jetzt Yes und das Ganze mit QEMO 4.1.1 und mal gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
Pass mal auf, jetzt haben wir die alte QEMO-Version, mit der es ja angeblich noch funktioniert.
Wie lang?
Gut, ich meinte so ziemlich alle Themen außer sowas, ja.
Lang genug für Gatschi-Buzz.
Aber jetzt hängt, da wobei man weiß nicht wirklich, ob es hängt, ja.
Es ist halt einfach lahm.
Vielleicht ist es auch ein Alpine-Gedöns.
Wir machen das einfach mal nicht.
Leute, ich glaube, ich habe eine Idee.
Yes.
Nur mal für den Fall der Fell, dass es jetzt irgendeine Alpine-Geschichte ist, dass es hängt.
Machen wir jetzt Bullseye daraus, falls der Tag genauso ist.
Ne.
Bitte Google das mal.
Was hat er?
Kann man danach googeln oder Gatschi-Buzz?
Ne.
Gut.
Was hat er denn getrieben?
Moment.
Bullseye Slim.
Mein Gott, wie soll man auf so eine Slim?
Jetzt.
Vielleicht ist es ja mit Alpine-Linux verpackt.
Wie haben wir heute so viel kaputtendes Zeug gehabt, man?
Das ist doch alles nicht mehr normal, ey.
Okay, also was ist da passiert?
Zeig her.
Okay.
Zusammenfassung, TLDR.
Das liegt...
Okay.
In der Show, in die von...
... wurden die Verbindungen des BSI-Präsidenten zu einem obskuren Verein offengelegt, der mutmaßlich
auch Kontakte zu russischen Geheimdiensten hat.
Gründer und Präsident des Vereins war zwar bis 2016 der heutige BSI-Präsident.
Der Verein nennt sich Cyber-Sicherheitsrat Deutschland e.V.
Also e.V. klingt irgendwie schon so...
Na gut, das heißt ja eigentlich nur eingetragener Verein, glaube.
Aber klingt ja irgendwie schon so ein bisschen, als hätte da mal einer ein Auge drauf.
So gerät mit seinem Namen Nähe zu offiziellen deutschen Regierungskreisen, hat aber nichts
mit einem Cyber-Sicherheitsrat zu tun, der im Verteidigungsministerium angesiedelt ist.
Na toll.
Das ist ja auch geil.
Denkst du dir beide...
Oh.
Crash.
Gut.
Also, das ist erwartet.
.NET tut nicht mit dieser QEMO-Version.
Dann nehmen wir doch mal die alte QEMO-Version und gucken, ob's mit der funktioniert.
Chat, was meint ihr, alte QEMO-Versionen gehen oder geht nicht?
Also ich persönlich tippe auf geht nicht, weil es ging die ganze Zeit auch schon nicht.
Wait a minute.
Soweit war mal vorher net.
Oder?
Nach drei Seiten Exceptions?
Soweit war mal vorher net.
Nice.
Okay, haben wir noch eine ältere QEMO-Version?
4.1, was haben wir noch?
4.1.0 vielleicht?
Hey, 4.1.0.
Wir machen jetzt einfach so alt die QEMO-Versionen, bis es funktioniert.
Pfeifert.
Irgendwann sind wir bei 0.5 und dann geht's.
Das ist quasi Reverse Versioning.
Wir ziehen einfach solange Versionen ab, bis es geht.
So, mal gucken, was jetzt passiert.
Okay, lesen wir mal kurz weiter.
Was haben wir denn sonst?
Also sie haben nichts damit zu tun.
Es hat aber nichts mit den Mitgliedern.
Es ist laut Angaben auf der Webseite unter anderem viele Unternehmen aus dem Finanzenergie-
und Sicherheitsbereich genannt werden, aber auch das Bundesgesundheitsministerium.
Die Polizeigewerkschaft, die deutsche...
Okay, bla.
Ebenfalls nicht die Protelion GmbH.
Sie ist laut Selbstdarstellung...
Okay.
Die Protelion GmbH ist aus dem russischen Unternehmen Infotex hervorgegangen, das mit
dem russischen Geheimdienst FSB zusammenarbeitet.
Wie viele Geheimdienste haben die eigentlich?
Die haben auf jeden Fall mehr als einen Geheimdienst.
Die haben wahrscheinlich alle Buchstabenabkürzungen durch.
Warum hat der BS...
Okay, ältere QEMO Version hat auch nichts gebracht, Leute.
Haben wir noch eine ältere QEMO Version?
Haben wir vielleicht 4.0?
Aha!
Und Leute, was meint ihr?
Fault!
Ich glaube auch, Sack Fault.
Ich glaube, was noch älteres gibt es nicht.
Was haben wir dann als nächstes?
3?
3.1?
3.2?
Das gibt es nicht, 3.1 hätte man dann bloß noch zu bieten.
Cack Fault.
Massive Cack Fault.
Moment.
Funktioniert hat es aber nicht.
Funktioniert hat es nicht.
Es hat...
Warte mal.
Hat es jetzt...
Die Ausgabe sieht man da drin hier anscheinend nicht, oder?
AMD.
Steht da da Hello World, wenn man das mit...
Also da müsste ja die Ausgabe drin stehen, wenn er das ausführt.
Die trosseln mich bestimmt schon bei Docker Hub und bei Microsoft.
Moment, man sieht das gar nicht, oder?
Oder, Moment, der wirft das irgendwie weg.
Wir machen noch mal einen Sleep drunter.
Sleep 5?
Ach nee, hier oben ist noch ein...
Echo drüber machen.
Nee, also...
Das ist ja doof, man.
Da sieht man überhaupt kein Standard Out.
Wo ist Wanker hin?
Oh, das Emote gibt es nicht mehr.
Ich habe es nicht gelöscht.
So, jetzt haben wir hier einen Image.
Kann man mit diesem Image jetzt was starten, oder ist das?
Ja.
Ich wiege ja das It.
App.
.NET Run.
Wollen wir doch nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass das mit dieser uralt QEMO Version geht
und das in viereinhalb Jahren niemand gefixt hat.
Es ist ja nicht so, als ist jetzt.NET so irgendwie...
Also bilden den Container und das der Scheiß funktioniert, Alter.
Gibt Cross Compiling Images mit.NET Build Tools.
Ja, ja, ja.
Aber für Arm 32 V7 ist das verbackt.
Docker Build was?
Minus Minus Progress Plane.
So.
Massive.
Das funktioniert.
Aus zum Teufel.
Ok, jetzt ist natürlich noch die Frage, ob mein.NET Publish funktioniert.
Chat, was meint ihr?
Ich meine, wenn.NET Run funktioniert, sollte.NET Publish eigentlich auch funktionieren.
Es lebt dann in 5,4.
Output können wir wegmachen.
Moment, das ist Arm die 64.
Moment, Arm die 64 brauchen wir nicht.
Wir brauchen Arm.
Sieht schon mal gut aus, sieht schon mal gut aus.
Also Alpine ist aber komplett verbackt.
Alpine hängt immer.
Aber die Debian Based Images funktionieren.
Ok, ok, ok, es sieht schon mal ganz gut aus.
Preview Version, Preview Version.
Base Debian.
Was mein Ziel ist, ich habe einen, ich möchte meinen Arm Container auf meinem Host bauen.
Mit einem, mit Coemo als Arm Emulator.
Es funkt, Leute.
Es geht, es geht.
Wir brauchen einfach nur die uralt Coemo Version, dann funktioniert es.
Wir brauchen eine vier Jahre alte Coemo Version, dann funktioniert es.
Bin.
Release.
Dotnet 7, ja, komm, Linux, Arm.
Wie habe ich es denn jetzt genannt?
Console?
Ne.
Wie heißt, wie heißt die, das Executable?
Ab, App, einfach nur App.
Hello World, da sind wir.
Krass, es funkt.
Ok, Moment, mit welcher Coemo Version hat es jetzt funktioniert?
4.0.0 minus 4, mit was anderem funktioniert es nicht, ne?
Also 4.1 war broken.
Nur mal, um das Ganze jetzt so zu verifizieren.
Ok, 4.1 ist broken.
4.0?
4.0 scheint zu funktionieren.
Alter, ich glaube, die lecken critical information bei Coemo.
Wie kann das sein, dass man vier Jahre so zurückgehen muss in die Version?
Na gut, es ist ja nur das Arm 32, also nur das 32-Bit-Arm-V7-Build.
Der Rest ist kaputt.
Was uralt Coemo oder Ubuntu 16.04, was?
Was ist mit Ubuntu 16.04?
Da habe ich jetzt nicht aufgepasst im Chat.
Was hat er denn geschrieben?
Schau mal hier, Building Instructions.
Ne, das will ich nicht machen.
Warum soll ich mein eigenes.NET bilden wollen?
Ich will doch nicht mein.NET bilden.
Warum soll ich denn.NET bilden wollen?
Ich will mein Programm bilden.
Leute, das funktioniert.
Das geht einfach.
Geil.
Ok, run slash app.
Wo schreibt man das hin?
slash app, build, release, app.
Wo publish?
Kann ich mir jetzt wieder net merken.
Publish und dann app zum Ausführen.
Hello World, Leute.
Zack, easy.
Uralt Coemo-Version, Leute.
So sieht es aus.
Massive 600 Jahre alte Coemo-Version.
Damit funktioniert es.
Easy.
Wie lange sind wir?
Leute, guckt mal.
Hä?
Warum zeigt es nicht an, wie lange ich online bin?
Das ist ein FFZ-Ding.
Ist der Online-Timer irgendein FFZ-Ding?
Leute.
Easy.
2 Stunden 44.
Ach, das ist das andere Wort.
Easy.
So, wir müssen jetzt so eine Sache testen, ob man damit überhaupt...
Was?
Was bin ich sehend?
Ich will nicht arm 64, ich brauch...
Nee, nee, Leute, das ist gedacht, wenn man.NET...
Das ist, wenn man.NET cross-compilen will.
Nicht mit.NET was cross-compilen.
Nicht mit.NET was bilden in einer emulierten Umgebung.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt noch mal eine Sache checken.
So, der 4-Champ.
Mal kurz klonen.
Kann ich sinnvollerweise das hier überhaupt drin kompilieren?
Also das ist jetzt ja mal eine bisschen größere Anwendung.
Git, clone.
So.
Der 4-Champ.
So, copy.
Wo sind wir denn hier?
Hier.
4-Champ.
Geile Ordnerstruktur, Mann.
So, also copy.
Copy.
Das da.
Nach slash...
App.
Warum sollte ich es irgendwie anders machen?
Das New können wir uns sparen.
Okay, mal gucken, ob der mal einen Addon bilden kann.
Ach so, slash App ist es ja nicht.
Es ist slash 4-Champ müsste das dann sein.
Aber sehen wir gleich.
Und vor allem, wie lange wird es dauern?
Hat jemand einen Blick auf...
Moment, die Uhr.
Ich habe gar keine...
Warum habe ich noch nicht mal eine Uhr?
Hier.
Da.
44.
45.
Das ist jetzt zum ersten Mal kein Hello World, was wir hier übersetzen.
Mach doch mit Time, aber dazu muss ich es wieder stoppen.
Ach, da unten.
Aber ohne Sekunden.
Na, das bildet wohl ein bisschen länger.
Aber es bildet immerhin, ohne dass es irgendwelche Fehler gibt.
Ja, das kann man natürlich als Parameter sogar...
Nee, das kann man schon als Variable machen.
Wäre sogar sinnig.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie lange das bildet.
Also ich meine, ich bin 14 Minuten noch on.
So, bis 23 Uhr.
Entweder ist bis dahin fertig gebildet oder nicht.
Aber das Hello World Programm hat, glaube ich, 70 Sekunden gebraucht.
Dann wird eine komplette Anwendung mit dem ganzen Krempel drum herum, das wird bestimmt
5-6 Minuten bilden.
Ich meine, wir sind in einer komplett emulierten Umgebung, in einer VM, wobei das...
Also das ist eine VM, es macht nicht so viel aus.
Das ist nicht Nested Virtualisierung, das ist Nested Emulation.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es diesen Begriff überhaupt schon gibt.
Nested Emulation.
Und als nächstes dann Docker in Docker-Bild.
Nested Emulation in VM.
Was ja bescheuerterweise in GitHub Actions so wäre.
GitHub Actions ist eine VM, worin ich dann den Docker starte.
Den Docker starte, der dann bildet für mich.
Also dafür gibt es kein Wort.
Wäre GitHub Actions Performanta?
Nee, bestimmt nicht.
Du hast mal ein KVM in VSL gemacht.
Muss man da nicht Nested Virtualisierung erst noch einschalten?
Wunder mich, dass es standardmäßig überhaupt geht.
Ja, muss man.
Na, ob das noch was wird hier?
KVM kann auch rein in Software arbeiten.
Wenn du noch so eine alte CPU hast, dass die noch keine
Hardware, also noch keine Virtualisierungsfunktion in der CPU hat.
Ja klar, das geht, aber halt nur auf der gleichen Plattform.
Das ist ja das, was VMWare früher auch gemacht hat.
Die haben halt irgendwelche Assembly, Umschreiben, Magic gemacht.
Das war aber auch damals schon relativ performant.
Auch ohne CPU-seitige Virtualisierungsunterstützung.
Es ist halt im Vergleich zu dem, was ich hier mache, ist es halt
der immer noch VM auf einem x86 für eine x86 VM und nicht eine
Arm-CPU in einer x86 VM.
Das ist ganz normales Gnome-Terminal, was ja wohl nicht
mal unterstützt wird, habe ich jetzt gelesen.
Okay Leute, ich fürchte, das wird mit dem Kompilieren heute nichts mehr, oder?
Der ist doch schon fünf Minuten jetzt dabei.
Warum eigentlich Gnome-Terminal in einem Window-Manager-Setup?
Weil ich Gnome-Terminal von der Bedienung ganz gut finde, bzw.
gut fand und ich das schon jahrelang verwende.
Und es ein Menü hat, wo man rechts klicken kann.
Die ganzen coolen neuen Terminals haben alle kein Rechtsklick-Menü.
Und ihr wisst, wie gerne ich rechts klicke und Einsen kopiere.
Wodurch wird es ersetzt, weiß ich nicht.
Wir müssen mal gucken.
Gnome-Terminal ist deprecated oder outdated oder sowas.
Tja.
Durch was wird es ersetzt?
Ich frage mich auch, Gnome-Konsole?
Nee, oder?
Ich hab letztens irgendwo gesehen, dass das deprecated ist.
Tja.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Man soll mir recht sein.
Ja, Konsole is aimed to replace.
Ja, swap Terminal in favor of Konsole.
Ja.
Terminal.
New applications, Konsole will replace Gnome-Terminal on G-Edit.
Okay.
Ja, ganz ehrlich, Gnome ist eh komplett lost mit dem, was sie da zusammenbauen.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, hängt das Ding oder braucht es einfach nur ewig zum Kompilieren?
Generell ist Desktop-Unterlinux komplett lost.
Das meint ihr, warum ich E3 verwende.
Einfach, weil ich nichts andere sinnvoll verwenden kann, weil alles suckt.
Und E3 hat halt nichts großartig zum Sacken.
Das hat ja nicht mal Fenster.
Na okay, in gewisser Weise hast du schon Fenster.
Du kannst ja immerhin sowas hier machen.
Aber, ja.
Leute, ich glaube, so schön das jetzt ist, dass wir eine Coemo-Version gefunden haben,
die potenziell funktionieren würde, eine ordentliche Anwendung kann man damit nicht übersetzen.
Wolltest du wirklich, ernst zu, bist du dir sicher, ich mag Suze überhaupt nicht.
Also, dann verwende ich lieber ein Ubuntu oder einen Mint oder irgendwas, aber kein Suze.
Suze mag ich überhaupt nicht.
Also, Arch, btw., sind wir uns ja einig, das ist eh das Beste.
Ja klar, aber wenn es was anderes sein muss.
sein muss. Ne, ich würd's sein lassen. Also Suze hab ich immer nur ganz eklige Sachen von
erlebt. Wir haben es ja auch ein paar mal im stream angeguckt.
Ne.
Warum? Ich willst unbedingt was RPM basiertes haben. Also wenn du was RPM basiertes haben willst, dann nimm lieber Fedora als Open Suze.
Open Suze finde ich ganz eklig und abfuck.
Abfuck. Aber ganz im Ernst Arch, by the way. Beste.
Auf dem Desktop wohlgemerkt. Server sieht das ganz anders aus. Auf dem Server wisst ihr, dass ich Ubuntu Fanboy bin, aber Debian ist auch okay.
Bei uns auf der Arbeit ist es zum größten Teil Red Hat beziehungsweise
CentOS, wobei es ja CentOS ab 8 in der Variante nicht mehr gibt.
Hannah Montana Linux ist doch auch irgendein Ubuntu mit einfach einem ausgetauschten Hintergrund.
By the way Arch, ja. Naja, man muss Prioritäten setzen.
Endeavor auf Desktop und Debian Server. Ja, das ist eine gute Kombination.
Der Package Manager nervt echt. Ich finde das ist eines mit der besten Sachen da dran.
Package Manager und User Repos. Ja, also ich würde sagen, Arch größer Fedora beziehungsweise Ubuntu Debian, alles und ganz am Ende kommt dann irgendwann Open Suze.
Da würde ich ja lieber noch irgendein Slackware oder so nehmen, bevor ich Open Suze nehme.
Das ist jetzt eine gemeine Frage, ja. Ich habe jetzt ganz oft, ich habe jetzt richtig abgelästert über Suze, jetzt muss ich mich wirklich noch dran erinnern, was da dran mich abgefuckt hat.
Könnt ihr mir das nicht einfach glauben und sagen, das ist so. Jetzt muss ich mir da auch noch mal was abfügen.
Ich hab's gestreamt, also kannst du dir mal schiefgucken. Was war dann eklig unter Open Suze? Lass mal überlegen. Mal gucken, ob ich da hingehe.
Also Zwipper fand ich abartig, das weiß ich noch, aber das ist bestimmt Gewöhnungssache.
Yast oder wie das Ding hieß, war weirdchamp, so irgendwie teilweise gehts, teilweise nicht. Software weiß ich gar nicht, ob das halbwegs aktuell ist oder nicht.
Aber Tumbleweed ist ja quasi so das Unstable von denen, ja.
Haben wir das noch im Archiv? Ich fand's eklig. Suze. Hier, Open Suze, 20 Jahre später. Ich kann mich nur noch dran erinnern, dass ich alles ziemlich, ziemlich eklig fand.
Ey, immerhin. Echt, kann man? Na, dann kann ich auch gleich Arch, by the way. Leute, das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal, tschüss.
Wie sieht denn das mit dem Bild? Wird doch nix mehr. Das hat sich entweder aufgehängt oder es ist kaputt oder es braucht einfach noch 30 Minuten.
Er hat ja immerhin angefangen offiziell. Hier, guck da. Wie sieht denn ein Bild aus, was funktioniert hat? Ach, cached.
Project zu Restore, Restored müsste eigentlich, Moment, der hat noch nicht mal richtig angefangen zu kompilieren. Der ist, der hat auch noch nicht mal angefangen zu Restore.
Okay, das ist, das ist pepega. Das wird, das wird nicht funktionieren, Leute. Grip. Gucken, vielleicht bringt's ja was, wenn ich neustelle.
Ich glaub, das ist, ich glaub, das ist prokken. Keine Chance. Nee, ernsthafte Projekte damit kompilieren kannst du nicht.
Illegal Instruction. Geht Cross-Compile nicht einfacher ohne, doch, doch, du kannst in.NET, ähm, mit ner, mit ner Option direkt ARM und, äh, also ARMv7 und ARMv8, äh, ja, ARM64 32-Spit-Reiß raushauen.
Das Schöne wäre, wenn das mit QEMU geht, das hier wäre mein komplettes Bild-File für alle Plattformen, für alle Images. Mehr bräuchte ich net. Sleep bräuchte mir gerade mal.
Mehr bräuchte ich net. Das wär, das war's. Wenn ich, wenn ich das anderweitig machen muss, dann müsste ich erst mal nen Container starten, also, äh, so Multistage-Build machen, ähm, erst mal nen Container starten für Build.
Also, äh, ein ARMv4, ein X6-Nachtcontainer starten, dem ich dann meine Anwendung baue und dann müsste ich noch für die Zielplattformen jeweils einzelne Container erstellen, wo ich das dann reinkopiere, ja.
Mit QEMU wär's halt einfach nice. Das wird einfach gehen. Bei GitHub Actions kann man auch die Zielplattform hochziehen. Nee, was meinste denn, wie die das machen?
Also, es kann sein, dass es irgendwelche Paid-Runner gibt, die auf ner Native-Arm-Kiste laufen, aber das meiste, was es gibt, ist, das ist QEMU unter der, unter der Haube.
Man kann den eigenen Raspberry Pi als, als Runner verwenden. Oh. Mit Matrix gibst du, glaub ich, an, was du für ne Betriebssystemversion verwenden willst.
Ja, genau. Ich sag ja, vielleicht gibt's was Paid. Vielleicht gibt es Paid irgendwas. Also, wenn du's, wenn du's mit den kostenlosen Actions machen willst, dann bleibt dir eigentlich nur QEMU übrig.
Und auch die ganzen Actions, die du findest, die machen im Prinzip nix anderes. Ja, wenn man zum Beispiel sucht, GitHub Actions. Ähm, ah, das erste, was du findest, ist dann sowas hier. Und das ist unter der Haube.
Das ist unter der Haube QEMU. Ja, using QEMU. Hier sogar mal ne offizielle Frage in der GitHub Community.
All x8664 architecture. Self-hosted runner.
Echt, es gibt welche Beta. GitHub Runner Arm Beta. Wäre natürlich praktisch. Ja, macOS kannst du, kannst du machen, aber das bringt dir nix.
In dem Fall. 64 Bit, 64 Bit Arm krieg ich anderweitig auch hin. Self-hosted runners. Ja, das ist klar.
Deswegen, es wäre halt praktisch gewesen. Anderweitig ist auch kein Problem. Wie gesagt, ich kann die.NET Anwendungen bilden und dann in die einzelnen Container verschieben. Das geht schon.
Aber so wäre es halt echt cool gewesen, wenn er das zweimal baut. Einmal für x86 und einmal für Arm. 32, gleiches Dockerfile, zack.
Warum ist Cross-Compiling eigentlich so schwierig? Es ist ja nicht Cross-Compiling. Es ist in einem Emulator kompilieren und in irgendeiner Art und Weise ist.NET verbackt oder QEMU verbackt.
Man weiß das nicht. Ach so, ich hab ein Browser. Man weiß es nicht so genau. Also entweder ist es ein QEMU Bug oder es ist ein.NET Bug. Aber es interessiert sich keiner dafür.
Da machst du nichts. Was 4.1 ging nicht.
Wie lernt man das eigentlich alles rumbasteln? Das andere bleibt dir da nicht übrig.
Ja gut, Paket sieht anders aus. Das ist eher so was, was wenn man sich da nicht hauptsächlich mit beschäftigt, lernt man das so nebenbei.
Ich hab damit angefangen 2012, 2011 oder so. Da war das noch relativ neu. Aber es war schon abzusehen, dass das der neueste Shit wird. Wir hatten damals unsere ganzen Server-Config-Management-Geschichten hatten wir noch in dem SVN liegen.
Und als ich das damals übernommen hab, hab ich gesagt komm wir machen das in Git. Da war das noch relativ neu. Und da musste ich mich monatelang mit Git beschäftigen und seitdem blick ich halbwegs durch.
Und ein paar neue Sachen gehen manchmal ein bisschen an mir vorbei. Wie zum Beispiel, dass du jetzt mittlerweile automatisch beim Rebase die Comments zusammenfassen kannst. Das wusste ich nicht. Hat mir sogar einer im Stream erzählt.
Ja guck mal das ist eh was komplett eigenes. Also das ist mit Abstand auch das größte Thema wenn man durchblicken will. Weil das zieht tausend Sachen nach sich.
Wenn du dann Cluster hast, dann kommen die ersten Ansagen. Ja wie siehts mit Updates aus? Ja wie siehts mit Loadbalancer aus? Ja wie siehts mit Dashboards aus? Ja wie siehts mit Metrics aus? Ja wie siehts mit Monitoring aus? Ja wie siehts mit Eingang aus? Ah wie siehts mit Ausgang aus? Sobald man damit anfängt ist vorbei.
Tja anscheinend ist es wirklich kaputt und es geht nur mit dieser einen QEMO Version. Und mit dieser einen QEMO Version lässt sich aber mein Projekt nicht bilden weil es kaputt ist. So. Nice.
Sehr schön. Also wir haben gelernt..NET Arm32 mit QEMO bauen ist nicht.
Das ist auch was. Das verwende ich auch nicht. Ich mache in meinem Kopf immer noch ins Dash und switche die Ordner. Und hier kannst du ganz mehrere Working Trees haben.
Das gab es damals noch nicht. Weiß gar nicht wann das eingeführt wurde.
Ja 2017. Da habe ich das so eine ganze Weile hinter mir gehabt. Gitbasics.
Welches Programm benutzt du für deine Linux-VM vor allem bei Workstation?
Guck.
Ja dann läuft es doch auf eine Multistage. Multidinks bums Bild raus und einzelne Dockerfiles beziehungsweise einzelne Configs für die Container.
Was solls. Ist halt. Ist halt dann so. Was willst du machen.
Oder ich mache irgendwie so ein kleines Skript was den Container startet das rauskopiert. Wir machen einfach gar kein Multistage Bild.
Das kompiliert das Ding kramisch legts irgendwo hin.
Dann macht es den Ziel Container. Mit Bild X.
Nee das geht ja nicht. Da kann ich ja zwischendurch nichts ausführen. Ach keine Ahnung.
Das bringt mir nichts. Multistage. Diese Home Assistant Addon Bilder kann kein Multistage.
Dann müsste ich beispielsweise auch. Da müsste ich dann selbst gucken.
Da müsste ich selbst in die Registry pushen den Container. Gucken dass das Namenschema stimmt. Sodass das Home Assistant Addon das checkt.
Da wäre es mir lieber ich könnte den fertigen Bilder von denen nehmen. Aber anscheinend. Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Leute das war heute echt anstrengend. Es hat nix funktioniert.
Muss ich mal was gucken. Wisst ihr was ich mir immer gerne angucke.
Was die Leute geklippt haben. Mal gucken was heute geklippt wurde.
Stimmt wo irgendwas nicht geht. Ich meine heute gab es nicht so wirklich viel tolles Zeug zum klippen.
Ja doch ein Clip Poggers.
Wenn ich es interaktiere.
Ok da ist einer aus Versehen aus Versehen auf die Clip Taste gekommen. Da ist ja gar nichts gewesen.
Was ist denn ein NPN was? Azure NPN Subscription. Also ich kenne diese einmalig 100 Euro gratis von Azure.
Und dann habe ich mal immer noch irgendwie 30 Tage was gekriegt.
So nach dieser Einschulung. Die übrigens übelst kacke war kann ich keinem empfehlen diese Azure Schulung.
Außer ihr wollt die Prüfung machen. Und auch nur weil ihr die dafür gemacht haben müsst.
Sag mal wie viele. Warum haben wir eigentlich so ziemlich alle Kacke Emotes die es gibt auf der Welt.
Oder ist das ein eigenes von dir.
Das ist was von dir ok. Nee das ist ein Twitch Emote. Das ist gar kein Bella Twitch TV Emote.
Das ist ein offizielles Twitch Emote. Ach so.
Ich dachte weil wenn man hier mal guckt wir haben nur wirklich alles alles an Kacke zu bieten was es gibt.
Und das auch.
Das ist eine Lizenz für die Firma ach so ok.
Geht das denn. Ich dachte du musst diese du musst die Schulung vorher gemacht haben dass du Prüfung machen kannst.
Also die Microsoft Schulungen sind wirklich richtig mies.
Es wäre tatsächlich gut wenn das geht die Prüfung zu machen ohne Schulung.
Weil die Schulungen sind dann holst du dir besser ein paar Vorbereitungsdinger.
Ganz im Ernst das ist so abartig langweilig.
Und der Dozent oder wie auch immer man den nennen mag der klickt auch nur PowerPoint Präsentationen durch.
Und der eine meinte halt das muss so sein weil Microsoft will dass die Schulungen einheitlich sind.
Da sind sie halt einheitlich scheiße.
Ein älteres Battlefield.
Ja warum nicht.
Leute ich geh ins Bett.
Wir sehen uns nämlich morgen früh schon wieder in ein paar Stunden.
Ja Escher Katze die Oberfläche ist auch abartig.
Wir sehen uns bald wieder Leute. Morgen früh gehts weiter. Bis denn. Machts gut.
See you.